I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Hi, everyone. Today we will be discussing Michael's last dundies in our first new recording space. Yes, we are renting the cutest space. Sam Cassie, say hello. We're all here. Hi, everyone. Hi. They're behind, uh, it's kind of like a shower curtain. Yeah, we can see them. This studio is so adorable. I have a coaster. You do. Like some of the personal
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当事两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。大家好。大家好。今天我们将讨论迈克尔的最后一次邓迪奖，这也是我们在全新录音室的第一期节目。是的，我们在租用一个超级可爱的空间。萨姆、卡西，打个招呼吧。我们都在这。大家好。嗨。他们就在，呃，有点像浴帘后面。是的，能看到他们。这个工作室太可爱了。我有一个杯垫。确实。就像某些个人
touches in the bathroom. It's clear that the owners have put up their children's artwork, which is so my thing. And Jenna, how would you say the temperature is in here? Sam, the temperature is just temperature. It's neither hot nor cold. Yes. And the table we're sitting at was the owner's grandmother's table. And it's the perfect height for me. Maybe she was petite and stature because I don't need my foot stool. It's very exciting. It's very exciting. So today in our new space, we will be discussing season seven episode 21, written by Mindy Kaling and directed by Mindy Kaling. Would you like a summary? I can't wait for it. I'm going to be honest with you. I struggled with this summary. Oh,
浴室里的布置。很明显，业主贴出了他们孩子的艺术品，这非常符合我的风格。珍娜，你觉得这里的温度怎么样？萨姆，温度就是温度。既不热也不冷。是的。我们坐的桌子是业主祖母的桌子。高度对我很合适。也许她身材娇小，因为我不需要脚凳。这非常令人兴奋。非常兴奋。所以今天在新空间里，我们将讨论第七季第21集，由明迪·卡灵编剧并导演。你想要一个剧情梗概吗？我都等不及了。老实说，我整理这个梗概时可费劲了。哦，
it seems like the title says it all. Mm hmm. So how do you expand on that? Here's what I got. Oh, well, you're really setting me up to be disappointed blown away. All right. It is time for Michael's last dundies. Michael taps D'Angelo to co-host his final Dundee Awards, but D'Angelo has massive stage fright. And Michael worries about his legacy continuing after he's gone. Meanwhile, Aaron's personal life takes a turn when she follows Pam's advice and everyone gives Michael a special send off. I would add one thing to that. What is it? Dwight's heart is broken. You're right. That is a major plot point. See, I struggled with the summary. I told you. All right. Fastback number one. Like I said, in the beginning,
看来剧名已经说明了一切。嗯哼。那怎么展开呢？这是我整理的。哦，你还真是把我架得很高，希望越大失望越大。好吧。是时候迎来迈克尔的最后一次邓迪奖了。迈克尔邀请德安杰洛共同主持他的最后一次邓迪奖颁奖典礼，但德安杰洛有严重的舞台恐惧症，而且迈克尔担心他离开后自己的传奇无法延续。与此同时，艾琳听从了帕姆的建议，个人生活发生了转折，大家也为迈克尔举行了特别的欢送仪式。我要补充一点。什么？德瓦特心碎了。没错。这确实是一个重要的情节看点。你看，我整理梗概时确实很纠结。我早就说过了。好吧。幕后速递第一条。正如我一开始所说，
this was written and directed by Mindy Kaling. You know, Mindy wrote the first Dundee's episode and this time around, she both wrote and directed the episode. Very exciting. Yes. And we reached out to Mindy. She's always so gracious. She always gets back to us right away. She got us audio clips a day earlier than our deadline. Yeah. She wrote back and said, you guys, let me rewatch it. I'll send you audio clips. We're going to sprinkle them throughout the episode. Well, first off, we asked her a bunch of questions about getting to write and direct this episode. And here's what she had to say.
这一集是由明迪·卡灵编剧和导演的。你知道，明迪写了第一集邓迪奖，而这一次，她兼任了该集的编剧和导演。非常令人兴奋。是的。我们联系了明迪。她总是那么亲切。她总是立刻回复我们。她比我们的截止日期提前一天把音频剪辑发了过来。是的。她回信说：“伙计们，让我重新看一遍。我会发给你们音频剪辑。我们会在这一集里穿插播放。”首先，我们问了她很多关于编剧和导演这一集的经历。以下是她的说法。
Hey, Jenna and Angela. Thanks for these incredibly thoughtful questions about Michael's last Dundee's. So I have to admit to you guys that I was feeling really vulnerable about this particular episode and revisiting it and watching it. And I tried to pinpoint why that is because I have nothing but joyous memories of working on the show. And I think the answer is because I directed this one. And I was so nervous directing the show because I loved writing for the show. And to this day, I think I've only directed two episodes of television and they were both from the office 16 years ago. So I love directing. I think it was awesome that Greg and Howard
嘿，珍娜和安吉拉。谢谢你们提出这些关于迈克尔最后一次邓迪奖的走心问题。我必须向你们坦白，对于这一集以及重新审视和观看它，我其实感到非常脆弱。我试图找出原因，因为我对参与这部剧只有快乐的回忆。我想答案是因为这一集是我导演的。我导演这部剧时非常紧张，因为我很喜欢为这部剧写剧本。直到今天，我想我只导演过两集电视剧，而且都是16年前的《办公室》。所以我热爱导演。我认为格雷格和霍华德
let me write and direct an episode of TV. In fact, it was their suggestion that I did it because I was too scared to volunteer. I think Greg chose for me to direct this episode because it was a bookend with the first Dundee's episode. But I don't think we ever spoke about that. Greg is not so sentimental that he would have been like, do you remember six years ago or seven years ago when you wrote the Dundee's and now we've come full circle? I mean, I wish he was that way. But he's just not. It's very funny. I had wondered how she got assigned to this episode. Since she had written the first one, I thought maybe it was intentional. Yeah. We also asked Mindy, what were some
让我编剧并导演一集电视剧真是太棒了。事实上，这是他们的建议，因为我太害怕不敢主动请缨了。我想格雷格选择让我导演这一集，是因为它与第一集邓迪奖前后呼应。但我不认为我们谈论过这一点。格雷格并不是那种多愁善感的人，会说：“你还记得六年前或七年前你写了邓迪奖，现在我们又回到了起点吗？”我是说，我希望他是那样的人。但他就是不这样。太好笑了。我一直好奇她是怎么被指派到这一集的。既然她写了第一集，我还以为是刻意的呢。是的。我们还问了明迪，
of the biggest differences between writing the first Dundee's and then writing and directing this one? Here's what she said. I think the biggest thing was how much more enjoyable it was for me to have written the first Dundee's than it was to write and direct this one from season seven. And which seems crazy because I was directing Carrell and Will Ferrell and obviously our amazing cast. I was directing a script I had written, which is like everybody's dream is to direct their own words. And I just remember being terrified. And I'll tell you what really terrified me. This is going to sound ridiculous, but making sure I didn't sleep through my alarm because
编剧第一集邓迪奖与编剧并导演这一集之间最大的区别是什么？她是这么说的。我觉得最大的一点是，写第一集邓迪奖比写和导演第七季这一集要愉快得多。这听起来似乎很疯狂，因为我要导演卡瑞尔、威尔·费瑞尔，当然还有我们出色的演员阵容。我在导演自己写的剧本，这就像是每个人的梦想——导演自己的台词。我只记得当时吓坏了。我告诉你们真正让我害怕的是什么。这听起来可能很荒谬，那就是确保闹钟响了我也没睡过头，因为
when you're a director, you have to be on time. It's not like an actor where you can kind of be eight minutes late and the hair and makeup team can kind of make up the time. It is such a bad book if you're not there. So I was really terrified. I also had the sense that this was an episode that was sort of important in the emotional arc of the series where Michael would be leaving and it was like our beloved Steve. And I think that we wrote the script with the Dundee's. It's always one of those ones where you have to come up with these like jokie jokes. And by jokie jokes, I mean the names of the Dundee Awards is not just like a joke from the office. It's like an extra joke. It has to be like
当你是个导演时，你必须准时。不像演员那样可以迟到八分钟，然后发型和化妆团队可以把时间补回来。如果你不在，那就太糟糕了。所以我真的很害怕。我还觉得这一集在剧集的感情弧光中相当重要，迈克尔即将离开，而且就像我们深爱的史蒂夫一样。我想我们在写邓迪奖的剧本时，总是需要想出这种插科打诨的笑话。所谓插科打诨的笑话，我是指邓迪奖的名字不只是《办公室》里的普通笑话，它是一个额外的笑话。它必须像是
something that a character on the show would come up with. So it can be funny, but not like so clever. So remember that being challenging. I mean, I have to imagine getting to pitch Dundee Award jokes is so much fun. I'm sure that took up a whole night. Right. I feel like there's like a list of possible Dundee's and they're all like so hilarious. We also wanted to know what it was like to direct Will Ferrell. Yes. Yeah. I mean, he's so funny. Here's what she had to say. You know, what's interesting was I remember Will Ferrell be incredibly kind. Like there's these photos taken from set of him kind of like looking to me like, Hey, was this good when
剧中的角色会想出的东西。所以它要好笑，但又不能显得太聪明。所以我记得那挺有挑战性的。我的意思是，想象一下提出邓迪奖的笑话一定非常有趣。我敢肯定那花了一整晚的时间。对吧。我觉得有一个潜在的邓迪奖列表，而且它们都超级搞笑。我们还想知道导演威尔·费瑞尔是什么体验。是的。是的。我的意思是，他太搞笑了。她对此是这么说的。你知道，有趣的是，我记得威尔·费瑞尔超级友善。比如片场拍到他的一些照片，他看着我好像在说：“嘿，这样好吗？”虽然
he absolutely did not have to do this. It's not like D'Angelo Vickers was this like challenging character for him. You know, he was just doing his thing. But I thought it was really nice that he was looking to me for input, you know, occasionally, which I thought was great. He's the best. I saw those pictures, by the way. Yeah. Yeah. I went to NBC's website and found all these office photos and there they are. Like he's kind of looking over her shoulder. She's pointing to the script. I was like, Oh, that's so like awesome that that was documented. Oh, my gosh, if I were her, I would have one of those framed in my house, like 11 by 14. But you would still introduce yourself to him. I would still you would hold up the picture
他完全没必要这么做。德安杰洛·维克斯对他来说并不是什么具有挑战性的角色。你知道，他只是在做他自己。但我认为他偶尔会向我征求意见，这真的很棒，我觉得太棒了。他是最棒的。顺便说一句，我看到过那些照片。是的。是的。我去了NBC的网站，找到了所有这些办公室的照片，它们就在那里。就像他有点越过她的肩膀看着。她指着剧本。当时我想：“哦，这被记录下来真是太棒了。”天哪，如果我是她，我会在家里裱一张这样的照片，比如11乘14尺寸的。但你还是会向他做自我介绍。我还是会，你会举起那张照片
and be like, Well, remember, I met him. I'd get a wallet size just for that purpose to remind him. Wouldn't be creepy at all. Are you ready for fastback number two? Yeah. It's a location alert. Ding, ding, ding, ding. Were you wondering where we filmed the dundies? I'll tell you, please do. I remember. Well, I know you were there speaking to our listeners. I was trying a new thing. The dundies are held at a fictitious restaurant called Louis Volpe, where the breadsticks apparently taste like crack. The exterior scenes when we're all out in the parking lot and the establishing shots were filmed at Barone's restaurant in Valley Glen, California. Yeah. The craft services guys would often order pizza from
说：“威尔，还记得吗？我见过他。”我会专门做一张钱包大小的来提醒他。一点也不诡异。你们准备好听幕后速递第二条了吗？是的。这是取景地提醒。叮，叮，叮，叮。你们想知道我们在哪里拍摄的邓迪奖吗？我来告诉你们，请吧。我记得。好吧，我知道你在对我们的听众说话。我在尝试一种新事物。邓迪奖在一个名为路易斯·沃尔佩的虚构餐厅举行，那里的面包棒显然吃起来像毒品一样让人上瘾。当我们都在停车场时的外景镜头和建立镜头是在加州峡谷镇的贝罗内餐厅拍摄的。是的。如果我们在片场工作到很晚，剧组的餐饮工作人员经常会从
Barone's if we were working late on set. So this was kind of a nice little wink and nod. I remember my very favorite pizza that we would get from there. Which one? Well, first of all, it's all Neapolitan style and it's like a rectangle, right? What's Neapolitan style mean? Like thin? Yeah. Yeah. My favorite order is the house combination. What's on it? Sausage, pepperoni and bell pepper. That sounds good. Well, I looked at their website and their pizza is a blend of recipes from six Italian families all related who created the original Barone's famous Italian restaurant, which opened in 1945. It's a Los Angeles landmark and it's delicious. And they are famous for their rectangular pizza. Do you know why?
贝罗内餐厅订披萨。所以这算是一个很好的致敬。我记得我从那里订的最喜欢的披萨是什么。哪一款？首先，它全是那不勒斯风格的，而且是长方形的，对吧？那不勒斯风格是什么意思？薄的吗？对。是的。我最点的是招牌混合披萨。里面有什么？香肠、意式辣香肠和甜椒。听起来不错。好吧，我看了他们的网站，他们的披萨是由六个有亲属关系的意大利家庭的食谱融合而成的，他们创造了最初著名的贝罗内意大利餐厅，该餐厅于1945年开业。这是洛杉矶的地标，而且非常美味。他们以长方形披萨闻名。你知道为什么吗？
It's a rectangle. I found out on the website, Angela. I don't. They put it in a rectangle because their first pizza ovens were kind of tiny and this way they could fit more pizza in there. It was just a space saver thing. Efficiency and it stuck. It did. Now the interior for the dundies was not filmed at Barone's restaurant. It was a set that we built over on our warehouse stages. Randy even sent us a blueprint of Michael Gallenberg's design. It is so elaborate. I know. There's like the restaurant with all the tables. There's the hallways. There's a fakie bathroom where D'Angelo's going to have to throw up. There's the host stand. He built a whole restaurant. And I remember walking through the fakie hallway
它是长方形的。我在网站上发现了，安吉拉。我不知道。他们把它做成长方形是因为他们最初的披萨烤炉有点小，这样他们就能在里面塞进更多披萨。这纯粹是为了节省空间。为了效率，然后就一直沿用了下来。确实如此。现在，邓迪奖的内景并不是在贝罗内餐厅拍摄的。这是我们在仓库搭景搭建的一个布景。兰迪甚至给我们发了迈克尔·加伦伯格设计的蓝图。它太精心了。我知道。有带所有桌子的餐厅。有走廊。还有一个假浴室，德安杰洛得在那儿呕吐。有接待台。他搭建了一整间餐厅。我记得走过假走廊
into the restaurant and it's so mind blowing. I don't even know how to explain to people what it's like. I shot a show splitting up together that had like a whole house and when you were in the stage, you felt like you were in a real house and then you would walk out the door and you were just in a warehouse. It's very mind bending. But the craziest thing about that house was that there were stairs to go upstairs but they didn't go anywhere. Yeah. It was just like a landing and then we would have to get in a golf cart and drive all the way over to a different warehouse on the lot where the upstairs stage was built. Very similar to I guess when we would have to do our elevator stuff on the office. We'd
进入餐厅时，太让人震撼了。我甚至不知道该怎么向大家解释那种感觉。我拍过一部剧叫《分道扬镳》，里面有一整栋房子，当你在摄影棚时，你感觉自己在一栋真正的房子里，然后你走出门，发现自己只是在一个仓库里。这非常颠覆认知。但那栋房子最疯狂的事情是，有楼梯可以上楼，但它们根本通往任何地方。是的。就只是一个平台，然后我们必须坐高尔夫球场巡逻车一直开到地块上的另一个仓库，二楼的布景就是建在那里的。这很相似，我想就像我们在《办公室》里做电梯桥段的时候一样。我们
have to relocate to a different building. That's one of my favorite things about sets. And when I watch shows now like Friends or anything like that, I think about like, oh, when they go up their stairs, I wonder if it was like us where we went upstairs and then just nothing. You would just like maybe just fall off a ladder or be wedged in a little tiny corner and you couldn't move. And I think about like, you know, Jennifer Aniston and Courtney Cox up there wedged in a corner. I don't know. I'm rewatching Friends guys. I'm thinking about this now. You started from the beginning. Yeah. How far are you? We're almost done. Wow. Yeah.
不得不搬到另一栋楼。这是我最喜欢布景的地方之一。现在当我观看像《老友记》或类似节目的剧集时，我会想，哦，当他们走上楼梯时，我不知道是不是像我们一样，走上楼去却什么都没有。你可能会从梯子上摔下来，或者被卡在一个小小的角落里动弹不得。我会想到像詹妮弗·安妮斯顿和柯特妮·考克斯被卡在那个角落里。我不知道。伙计们，我在重温《老友记》。我正在考虑这个。你是从头开始看的吗？对。你看到哪了？我们快看完了。哇。是的。
Wow. Follow up to office ladies. Would it be weird if we rewatched Friends? We weren't on it. Maybe. I don't know. We'll see. Just a thought. All right. Last part of this fast fact. Do you remember the website we talked about before? It's called I am not a stalker with the scowl Lindsey who visits the locations of places made famous on TV or in movies. Yes. I've seen her website. Yes. It's fascinating. Well, she did a really fun blog where she went to Barone's and she took pictures of the interior of the real Barone's. So if you want to see it, it's all on her blog. And while we did not film there, the interior of the restaurant is featured in the movies. Fast Times at Ridgemont High and the Billy
哇。办公室女士们的续集？如果我们重温《老友记》会不会很奇怪？我们又没有参演。也许吧。我不知道。走着瞧吧。只是个想法。好吧。这则幕后速递的最后一部分。还记得我们之前讨论过的那个网站吗？它叫“我不是跟踪狂”，那个叫林赛的怪人会去参观在电视或电影中成名的地方。是的。我看过她的网站。是的。这太迷人了。好吧，她写了一篇非常有趣的博客，讲述了她去贝罗内餐厅并拍摄了真正贝罗内餐厅内部的照片。所以如果你想看，都在她的博客上。虽然我们没有在那里拍摄，但餐厅的内部曾出现在电影《开放的美国学府》和比利·
Bob Thornton Movie Bad News Bears. If you go there and you go to the bathroom and you walk through that one big part of the restaurant they hardly ever use, you know, I don't. I've never eaten there in person. What? I've never eaten there in person. We need a BFF date there. You know, as soon as when I was looking at the website, I thought, why don't I eat here all the time? Oh, I've eaten there so many times. We go there for like kids' birthdays and stuff. It's super fun. But when you walk to the bathroom, there are so many paintings. So many paintings of what? You name it. A ye olde boat in a rough sea in some far land. It's I love all the paintings. It's just a hallway of paintings. It's like a big empty
鲍勃·松顿的电影《少壮经》中。如果你去那里，去了洗手间，穿过了餐厅里那个几乎从不用的大区域，你知道吗，我不知道。我从来没有亲自去那里吃过饭。什么？我从来没有亲自去那里吃过饭。我们得去那里进行一次闺蜜约会。你知道，当我看着网站时，我在想，我为什么不一直在这吃呢？哦，我在那吃过好多次了。我们去那里庆祝孩子们的生日什么的。超级有趣。但当你走向洗手间时，有那么多的画作。到底画了什么？应有尽有。一艘古老的船在汹涌的海面上驶向某个远方的大陆。我爱所有的画作。那简直就是一条画廊走廊。就像一个巨大的空荡荡的
room of paintings. Anyway, anyway, we're going to go and then we're going to both get up and go with the bathroom at the same time. And I'm going to show you these paintings. Well, that's my location breakdown. Angela, you requested fast fact three. You know, it's my favorite thing when you ask for a fast fact. I did. Okay. One second, because I need to change clothes. What is happening? Oh my gosh. Angela just got out a red bow tie. She's putting on a jacket, a black blazer, a black blazer and a red bow tie. She's getting out boxes that say our names on them. I don't know. She's getting out boxes. All right. Sam, hit it. Is this the price is right theme song? Oh, it's just Oh, oh my God. Oh my God.
画室。不管怎样，不管怎样，我们要去了，然后我们会同时起身上洗手间。我要给你看这些画。好吧，这就是我的取景地剖析。安吉拉，你要求了幕后速递第三条。你知道，每当你要求幕后速递时，这就是我最喜欢的事。我确实要求了。好吧。等一下，因为我需要换衣服。这到底是怎么回事？哦，天哪。安吉拉拿出了一个红领结。她正在穿夹克，一件黑色西装外套，一件黑色西装外套和一个红领结。她拿出了写着我们名字的盒子。我不知道。她拿出了盒子。好吧。萨姆，开始吧。这是《价格是正确的》主题曲吗？哦，只是，哦，哦，天哪。哦，天哪。
Thank you. Thank you very much. Welcome to office, ladies, Dundee's or as D'Angelo Vickers would say, get them to the Dundee's. Our first Dundee goes out to someone who keeps us all going. And she might just have a great hand with some clacky balls. Cassie Jerkens, come on up here. You win the best ball detangler, Dundee. Come on. Speech, speech, speech. Wow. Thank you so much, Dundee's. I can't believe it. You worked really hard for it. Let's give it up for Cassie. Cassie. Our next Dundee goes to our fellow Sam, who gives us as many lamps as we want. He also shares knowledge with us from the Urban Dictionary and the Dark Web. And on occasion, he loves to go off on a certain television show. Sam,
谢谢你们。非常感谢。欢迎来到“办公室女士”邓迪奖，或者用德安杰洛·维克斯的话说，“把他们带到邓迪奖”。我们的第一个邓迪奖颁给一个让我们所有人坚持下去的人。而且她可能非常擅长玩那些弹力球。卡西·杰肯斯，请上台。你赢得了最佳球类解结奖，邓迪奖。来吧。发表获奖感言，发言，发言。哇。非常感谢，邓迪奖。我真不敢相信。你为此付出了很多努力。让我们为卡西鼓掌。卡西。我们的下一个邓迪奖颁给我们的伙伴萨姆，他给了我们想要的任意多的灯光。他还跟我们分享来自“城市词典”和暗网的知识。有时，他喜欢对某部电视剧大加挞伐。萨姆，
come on up here. You win the biggest Emily in Paris hater. Biggest Emily in Paris hater. Speech. She's just not a good person. All right. And last but not least to my BFF and my co-office lady who does the best deep dives ever, but might also have a problem loudly swallowing. Jenna Fisher, get on up here because you just won the cut swallow Dundee. Speech, speech. Thank you. I feel like we need to explain cut swallow for everyone. Sometimes when we edit, Jenna really focuses on her swallowing and she'll go, Sam, at five minutes, 15 seconds, can you and Cassie cut my swallow? Can someone cut swallow? Oh my God, I swallowed again. Can someone cut that swallow? Oh, yeah. To be fair, we are sometimes cutting
请上台。你赢得了“最大的《艾米丽在巴黎》黑粉奖”。最大《艾米丽在巴黎》黑粉奖。发表感言。她实在不是个好人。好吧。最后但同样重要的是，颁给我最好的闺蜜和办公室搭档，她做了史上最棒的深度挖掘，但可能也有大声吞咽的毛病。珍娜·费舍，快上台，因为你刚刚赢得了最佳吞咽声邓迪奖。发言，发言。谢谢。我觉得我们需要向大家解释一下“切断吞咽声”。有时当我们剪辑时，珍娜真的很关注她的吞咽动作，她会说：“萨姆，在5分15秒，你和卡西能帮我剪掉吞咽声吗？有人能剪掉吞咽声吗？哦，天哪，我又吞咽了。有人能把那个吞咽声剪掉吗？”哦，是的。说实话，有时候我们确实在帮你剪掉
your swallows, Angela. Sometimes, sometimes, but you win best swallow. Wow. Wow. My husband will be so excited. Oh, yeah. Where's my, oh yeah, Sam. Oh, yeah. I sent a request of sound effects to Sam last night and then I told him and Cassie today to have as much fun as Dwight has at a keyboard as I gave out my awards. Remind me to make you one of these that says latest e-mailer. Yes. I got some solid one a.m. I got an e-mail last night. It's one in the morning. Hey, do you have fart sounds? It was not. It was like 11. Yeah, Angela, where's your Dundee? This was so fun. You didn't make yourself a Dundee. That doesn't seem like fitting. Okay, guys, Sam, Cassie, me, during this next break, we're
吞咽声，安吉拉。有时，有时，但你赢得了最佳吞咽奖。哇。哇。我丈夫会非常兴奋的。哦，对了。我的，哦对了，萨姆。哦，对了。我昨晚向萨姆发出了音效请求，然后我今天告诉他和卡西，让我颁奖时要像德瓦特在键盘前一样玩得开心。提醒我给你做一个写着“最新邮件发送者”的奖杯。是的。我昨晚收到了一封扎实的凌晨一点的邮件。那是凌晨一点。嘿，你有放屁的声音吗？根本没有。大约是11点。是的，安吉拉，你的邓迪奖呢？这太有趣了。你没有给自己做个邓迪奖。这好像不太合适。好吧，伙计们，萨姆、卡西、我，在接下来的休息时间，
going to have a little conference and we're going to come back with what your Dundee award would be. Okay, enjoy. Yay. Oh, what a fun way to kick off this episode. I love it. All right, that was Office Ladies Dundees. We'll be right back and break down this episode. All right, we are back and Angela, the team and I discussed your Dundee and here's what we've decided to award you. Yeah, Angela Kinsey, you win the Dundee award for Best Visual Bits for an Audio Podcast. Putting in the jokes no one will ever see. Yay. I love it. Way to go, Angela. Someday, when we televised our podcast, which will be never, all of it will pay off. You guys, Jenna did share that she, oh, he's my speech. Thank
我们要开个小会，然后回来宣布你的邓迪奖会是什么。好吧，享受吧。耶。哦，开启这一集的方式太有趣了。我太喜欢了。好吧，那是“办公室女士”邓迪奖。我们马上回来并剖析这一集。好吧，我们回来了，安吉拉，团队和我讨论了你的邓迪奖，这是我们决定授予你的奖项。耶，安吉拉·金斯利，你获得了播客最佳视觉笑话的邓迪奖。加入了永远不会有人看到的笑话。耶。我太喜欢了。干得好，安吉拉。总有一天，当我们把播客搬上电视时——这永远不可能发生——这一切都会得到回报。伙计们，珍娜确实分享说她，哦，这是我的演讲。谢谢
you. I'm going to act out my speech. Jenna did share with us during the break that she felt like she had a true Pam moment because as I was doing the Dundee awards, she started to tear up because she thought I was going to award her for Best Deep Dive, which now I feel horrible. I mean, you sort of mentioned the deep dives and I, I mean, I wasn't expecting it, but I just swelled with pride to receive an award for this thing that I take such care with and I was like, oh my gosh, it's happening. And then I got Best Cut Swallow and it just felt so similar to the longest engagement. All the wind went out of her sails. You should have seen her face when I said Cut Swallow. I want you to know last night as I was making
你们。我要表演我的演讲。珍娜在休息期间与我们分享说她觉得自己有一种真正的帕姆时刻，因为当我颁发邓迪奖时，她开始落泪，因为她以为我会颁给她最佳深度挖掘奖，现在我觉得太糟糕了。我的意思是，你算是提到了深度挖掘，而我，我的意思是，我并没有期待，但我内心涌起一股自豪感，因为我获得了这个我如此用心对待的事物的奖项，当时我想：“哦，天哪，它要发生了。”然后我得到了最佳吞咽剪辑奖，这感觉太像那场漫长的订婚了。所有的热情一下子都泄气了。如果你看到我说出“吞咽剪辑”时她的脸。我想让你们知道，昨晚我在制作
these, I was brainstorming with my husband about what to give everyone and he said, you should give Jenna like a Best Deep Dive. And I said, that's not funny. They all have to be cheeky and Michael Scott like, thank you, Josh. There you go. Thank you for seeing me. Maybe next year on Office Ladies Dundees, Jenna. Maybe next year. I have, we'll have to see. Yeah. Well, we should get started. It's six AM, six AM. So early. And Michael and DeAngelo are about to deliver the Dundee nomination certificates. Why did they drive all the way to Dundermythland to meet up? Why didn't they just meet up at the first person's house? So many questions about all of this. And apparently Michael's been doing this
这些的时候，我和我丈夫集思广益，讨论该给每个人什么奖项，他说：“你应该给珍娜颁发一个最佳深度挖掘奖。”我说：“那不好笑。它们都必须是俏皮的、像迈克尔·斯科特式的。”谢谢你，乔希。给你。谢谢你看到我。也许明年在“办公室女士”邓迪奖上，珍娜。也许明年。我得，我们拭目以待。好吧，我们该开始了。早上六点，早上六点。太早了。迈克尔和德安杰洛正准备发放邓迪奖提名证书。为什么他们要开车一路大老远去“邓德米夫兰”见面？为什么不直接在第一个人的家里见面？关于这一切有太多的疑问。显然迈克尔一直在这样做
every year. So everyone at Dundermythland has tons of framed like Dundermythland like certificates of not their nomination. Well, you're assuming people are keeping these items. That's true. I mean, that's true. Stanley, Stanley doesn't even let them bring it in the house. They just leave it on the front porch. Yes, they go to Stanley's house. He tells them to, you know, get off his lawn. They go to Jim and Pam's house. Jim answers and his PJs and Pam yells, what is it? He's like, stay in bed. I showed up to work for that. Did you really? I did. I stood deep in that house and I yelled, what is it? Then they go to Toby's house not to give him a certificate just to egg his house. Yeah. Randy
每年如此。所以“邓德米夫兰”的每个人都有大量裱起来的像“邓德米夫兰”提名证书之类的东西。好吧，你这是在假设人们会把这些东西留着。这倒也是。我的意思是，这确实如此。斯坦利，斯坦利甚至不让他们把东西拿进屋里。他们只是把它留在前廊上。是的，他们去了斯坦利的草坪。他告诉他们，你知道，滚出他的草坪。他们去了吉姆和帕姆的家。吉姆穿着睡衣应门，帕姆大喊：“是谁呀？”他说：“留在床上。”我为了那个出场了。真的吗？真的。我深陷那个房子里大喊：“是谁呀？”然后他们去了托比家，不是为了给他证书，而是去砸他的鸡蛋。是的。兰迪
said they really threw eggs at a house and then they had to clean it up. I mean, it must have been a little bit fun. Just throw eggs at something. Yeah. The next stop is Meredith 's house and they beat her there. She's going to walk up the driveway, walk a shame, busted. I would like to point out at one minute, 23 seconds, maybe for the first time ever in the history of office ladies, a hummingbird feeder catch on Meredith's front porch. I'll tell you my favorite moment of her walking up onto her porch is how she walks into her wind chime and it goes off. It's really funny. I loved Kate's performance in this. I love when as Meredith, she's like, no, no, no, I have Vienna sausages. I have napkins. I'm
说他们真的往一栋房子上扔了鸡蛋，然后他们不得不清理干净。我的意思是，扔鸡蛋砸点东西一定挺有意思的。下一站是梅雷迪思的家，他们比她先到。她要走上车道，带着羞耻感走过去，当场抓获。我想指出的是，在1分23秒时，可能在“办公室女士”历史上破天荒第一次，梅雷迪思的前廊上拍到了一只蜂鸟喂食器。我来告诉你我最喜欢的她走上门廊的时刻，她是撞上了自己的风铃，然后风铃响了。这真的很好笑。我喜欢凯特在这场戏中的表演。我喜欢作为梅雷迪思的她，表现得像：“不，不，不，我有维也纳香肠。我有餐巾纸。我，让我给你们做早餐。”我在剧本中查过，德安杰洛和迈克尔之间的最后几句台词
going to let me fix your breakfast. I looked in the script and the last couplet of lines between D'Angelo and Michael were not in the shooting draft. Oh, so when D'Angelo whispers, I'm not going in there. And Michael says, go, go, go. That was not in the script. We had a fan question from Rachel H in Colorado Springs, Colorado. When Michael and D'Angelo are delivering Dundee nominations, Michael says he's never seen Meredith's house in the daylight. To me, this implies he has seen it at night. Could this mean that Michael and Meredith have hooked up? Is there any other reason why he would have seen it at night? I think he's given Meredith some rides home because she's had too much to drink before.
并没有出现在拍摄初稿中。哦，所以当德安杰洛低声说“我才不进去”而迈克尔说“去去去”时。剧本里并没有。我们收到了来自科罗拉多州科罗拉多斯普林斯的粉丝Rachel H的问题。当迈克尔和德安杰洛在颁发邓迪奖提名时，迈克尔说他从未在白天见过梅雷迪思的房子。对我来说，这意味着他曾在晚上见过。这是否意味着迈克尔和梅雷迪思曾在一块儿过夜？除此之外，他还有什么理由在晚上见过她的房子？我想他曾送梅雷迪思回家，因为她之前喝了太多酒。
That's where my brain went. Yeah, I don't think they've hooked up. I don't think they've hooked up. Yeah. So Randy told us that they found all these houses where all of the employees lived kind of in one neighborhood because they were going to try to knock out these scenes as quickly as possible. And Steve Rothstein and our set dressing crew, they would do things to the outside of the houses to make them, you know, make sense for our characters. Well, I found this old interview that Kate did where she talked about how, you know, we were not going to go inside her house or any of the houses, but she had to walk in, right? Yeah. But we were never going to film the inside of the houses. She said the inside
我的大脑是这么想的。是的，我不认为他们在一块儿过夜过。我不认为他们在一块儿过夜过。是的。所以兰迪告诉我们，他们找到了所有员工居住的房子，它们都在同一个社区里，因为他们打算尽可能快地拍完这些场景。史蒂夫·罗斯丁和我们的布景装饰团队会对房屋外部做一些处理，使它们，你知道的，符合我们角色的设定。好吧，我找到了凯特做的一篇旧采访，她在采访中谈到，你知道，我们不会进她的房子或任何人的房子，但她得走进去，对吧？是的。但我们从不打算拍摄房子的内部。她说这栋房子的内部
of this house was like really how she would imagine Meredith would live. It was like a true hoarder house. Here's what she said, quote, this was like a gorilla shoot. It's not like they did much set dressing. They just found this house and we got in a van. And I walked into the house for the first time, we did a rehearsal on camera and I could not believe it. It was like a hoarder's house, paper stacked up in pizza boxes from floor to ceiling. It was bizarre. I'm sure they did some set dressing on the outside and they really sold it. And I'm sure whatever Kate saw inside was maybe just the person that lived there. Yeah. Well, I love seeing people's homes. I mean, I know we'd already seen Jim
真的很像她想象中梅雷迪思会生活的地方。就像一栋真正的囤积者的房子。她是这么说的，引述：“这就像是一场游击拍摄。并不是说他们做了多少布景装饰。他们只是找到了这栋房子，然后我们上了一辆面包车。我第一次走进房子，我们在镜头前排练了一下，简直不敢相信。这就像是一栋囤积狂的房子，从地板到天花板都堆满了纸张和披萨盒。太离奇了。”我确信他们在外部做了一些布景装饰，而且真的很逼真。而且我确信凯特在里面看到的可能只是住在那里的人的真实状况。是的。好吧，我很喜欢看人们的家。我的意思是，我知道我们已经看过吉姆
and Pam, but that's one of the things I always wanted to do in the show. And I remember I pitched to Paul one time, I was like, can we have an episode where we go to a few people's houses? He's like, Angela, it's called the office. I know. I mean, I know over the years we had a few get-togethers at Michael's condo and like Gabe's apartment, but like he was like, no, Angela, we can't just keep going to people's houses. Well, now this episode is going to get started and Michael is going to walk in the door and ask Aaron what her plans are for that night. Yeah, Aaron really fakes him out. She's pretending that she forgot all about the dundies, but then she's so excited and she holds up her certificate and she's
和帕姆的家了，但那是我一直想在剧中做的事情之一。我记得我曾向保罗提议过一次，我说：“我们能拍一集去几个人的家里吗？”他说：“安吉拉，这叫《办公室》。”我知道。我的意思是，我知道这些年来我们在迈克尔的公寓和盖布的公寓里有过几次聚会，但他当时说：“不，安吉拉，我们不能总是去别人的家里。”好吧，现在这一集要开始了，迈克尔将走过门，问艾琳她那天晚上的计划是什么。是的，艾琳真的把他给忽悠了。她假装把邓迪奖忘得一干二净，但随后她又超级兴奋，举起她的证书说：“我要去邓迪奖。”在2分21秒时，
like, I'm going to the dundies. At two minutes and 21 seconds, I noticed that there's caramels in the candy dish. I think this might be the first time we've had kind of a sticky chewy candy in there. So it's a big catch, everybody. This is breaking news, everybody. Sticky candy at reception. Maybe that's your next dundee. Sticky candy. I didn't put it there. Best spotter. I mean, I think my next dundee could just be best deep dive, but I don't want to tell you how to run your dundies. You know what I'm positive of? Every office lady's dundies I host, you're not going to get the award you wanted. Well, that's clear. And started.
我注意到糖果盘里有焦糖。我想这可能是我们第一次在里面放这种又粘又耐嚼的糖果。所以这是一个大发现，各位。这是突发新闻，各位。前台有黏牙糖。也许这就是你的下一个邓迪奖。黏牙糖。可不是我放的。最佳发现者。我的意思是，我觉得我的下一个邓迪奖可以直接是最佳深度挖掘奖，但我不想教你怎么操办邓迪奖。我能确定的是什么？由我主持的每一届“办公室女士”邓迪奖，你都拿不到你想要的奖项。好吧，这很明显。开始吧。
Michael's going to have a talking head where he shows just how important the dundies are to him. You know, this is his legacy that he's going to be passing on. He gets really excited. He addresses the whole group kind of amping up the night and you know, Jenna, we have had many debates on this podcast about when Jim and Pam's first kiss was. We all know your thoughts, but I think the shooting draft for this episode might solve this question for us. Really? I'm intrigued. This scene would have started with D'Angelo saying, for those of us who've never experienced a Dundee Awards, I've asked Michael to talk a little bit about it. Then Michael would have said, it is a magical night, D'Angelo. And not just because
迈克尔将有一个访谈片段，在其中展示邓迪奖对他的重要性。你知道，这是他要传承下去的遗产。他变得非常兴奋。他向整个团队发表讲话，为这个夜晚预热，你知道的，珍娜，我们在这个播客上就吉姆和帕姆的初吻是什么时候进行过很多次辩论。我们都知道你的想法，但我认为这一集的拍摄初稿可能会为我们解决这个问题。真的吗？我很感兴趣。这一场戏本该以德安杰洛的话开始：“对于我们这些从未经历过邓迪奖的人来说，我请迈克尔谈谈它。”然后迈克尔会说：“这是一个神奇的夜晚，德安杰洛。不仅仅是因为
we recognize fellow employees, people fall in love. Pam and Jim had their first kiss there. And then the script says, Pam and Jim look at each other and smile a little. Then Dwight says, Pam got so drunk she fell out of a chair. And then Michael says, yes, anything can happen, like the Golden Globes, but less mean. Wow. Wow. Yeah. All right. I guess it might be time for me to accept that Jim and Pam's first kiss was at the Dundee's. Yeah. Okay. As an actor, I accept what has been scripted. You know, that's our job. Yeah. Right. That's the truth. We had a fan question from Julia P in Indiana who said, Dwight has a great line in the scene
我们表彰了同仁，人们还坠入爱河。帕姆和吉姆在那里有了他们的初吻。”然后剧本写道：“帕姆和吉姆相视一笑。”接着德瓦特说：“帕姆喝得太醉，从椅子上摔了下去。”然后迈克尔说：“是的，什么都有可能发生，就像金球奖，但没那么刻薄。”哇。哇。是的。好吧。我想我可能得接受吉姆和帕姆的初吻是在邓迪奖上这个设定了。好吧。作为一名演员，我接受剧本里写的内容。你知道，那是我们的工作。是的。对吧。这就是真相。我们收到了来自印第安纳州Julia P的粉丝提问，她说：“在这场戏里，
where he's discussing the dress code for the Dundee's with Michael Scott. When Michael says, it is black tie optional. And Dwight replies, every day is black tie optional. Julia would like us to know, quote, I don't always agree with Dwight, but as someone who loves any excuse to dress up a bit, I loved this line. I also liked this line. But I'll tell you, I did look up what black tie optional means. Yeah. And black tie optional actually means you're supposed to get really, really dressed up and you can wear a tuxedo and a full length gown if you want. If you don't want to wear those things, you still need to dress it up. So black tie optional does not mean you can show up in casual clothing. So Dwight is wrong.
德瓦特与迈克尔·斯科特讨论邓迪奖着装规范时有一句很棒的台词。当迈克尔说‘这是可选黑领带’时，德瓦特回答说‘每一天都是可选黑领带’。”朱莉娅想让我们知道，引述：“我并不总是同意德瓦特的话，但作为任何借口都喜欢盛装打扮的人，我太喜欢这句台词了。”我也喜欢这句台词。但我得告诉你，我确实查过什么是可选黑领带。是的。可选黑领带实际上意味着你应该盛装打扮，如果你愿意，你可以穿燕尾服和全长礼服。如果你不想穿那些，你仍然需要穿得很正式。所以可选黑领带并不意味着你可以穿着休闲装出现。所以德瓦特是错的。
And Angela has already picked both options today in one podcast recording. She has. She's gone both black tie optional and casual. We had another fan question from Test W in Virginia who said, I always thought it was interesting that Pam and Ryan get on each other's nerves during the later seasons. Oh, is she talking about the scene I call back to back sass? Yes, please describe Angela. Phyllis, they're talking about the breadsticks at the restaurant. Phyllis says, I love their breadsticks. Pam says, Oh, their breadsticks are like crack. Ryan says, I love when people say like crack when they've obviously never done crack.
而安吉拉今天在一次播客录音中就已经选了这两种选项。她确实选了。她既选择了可选黑领带，又选择了休闲装。我们收到了来自弗吉尼亚州Test W的另一个粉丝提问，她说：“我一直觉得有趣的是，帕姆和瑞安在后几季中总是互相惹恼对方。”哦，她是在说我称之为“针锋相对”的那场戏吗？是的，请安吉拉描述一下。菲利斯，他们在谈论餐厅里的面包棒。菲利斯说：“我爱他们的面包棒。”帕姆说：“哦，他们的面包棒就像毒品一样让人上瘾。”瑞安说：“我讨厌人们明明从没吸过毒却说像毒品一样。”
Pam says, Well, the breadsticks are like what then Ryan? What can I use? Ryan says, I don't know something from your world. The breadsticks are like scrapbooking. Pam says, You're right. You're right. I'm a middle class fraud. Well, test pointed out that they grew so close during the Michael Scott paper company arc. When and why do you think they started to dislike each other? Tess, I'll tell you, it all started right here. Mindy had written this scene for me and BJ, and we couldn't get through it because we kept laughing about it. It was so funny to us, this dialogue. But then people really liked this
帕姆说：“好吧，那面包棒就像什么呢，瑞安？我能用什么？”瑞安说：“我不知道，用点你那个世界的东西。面包棒就像剪贴簿。”帕姆说：“你说得对。你说得对。我是一个中产阶级的骗子。”嗯，泰丝指出他们在迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司的剧情弧光中变得非常亲密。你认为他们是什么时候以及为什么开始讨厌对方的？泰丝，我来告诉你，这一切就从这里开始。明迪为我和BJ写了这场戏，我们根本演不下去，因为我们一直为此发笑。这段对白对我们来说太搞笑了。但后来人们真的很喜欢这种
bickering. And so it's going to continue. But it kind of started here over this thing about the breadsticks. Yeah, I feel like this one is the one that knocked it out of the park. But you guys have always bickered a little bit here and there. It's true. It's true. But now we're really going to start amping it up. Michael is now going to reveal that his Dundee's co-host will be D'Angelo. Dwight is Crestfallen. Always the Padawan, never the Jedi. I did not understand that reference. Padawan? What's a Padawan? It's like the apprentice to the Jedi. Oh, but then, right, the Jedi is the best thing. Yeah. What's a Jedi? A Jedi? What is a Jedi? Yeah, is that, are you like, is that like a plane fighter? Like you drive the plane?
拌嘴。所以它将继续下去。但它确实从这里开始，因为面包棒这件事。是的，我觉得这一集是那种大获成功的。但你们俩一直以来都多多少少有点小拌嘴。确实如此。确实如此。但现在我们要真正开始加码了。迈克尔现在将透露，他的邓迪奖联合主持人将是德安杰洛。德瓦特大受打击。永远是学徒，绝不是绝地武士。我不懂那个梗。学徒？什么是学徒？就像绝地武士的徒弟。哦，但随后，对吧，绝地武士是最棒的。是的。什么是绝地武士？绝地武士？什么是绝地武士？是的，那是，你是说，那就像是开飞机的战斗机飞行员吗？就像你开飞机吗？
And you drive the plane? Is it like, you know, the pilot? Are you the pilot, the fighter pilot? Is a Jedi a fighter pilot? The Jedi is the person that can channel the force and use the force in battle. Is there only one Jedi? I'm getting viscerally mad. There's so many Jedi's. I can't even believe that you're like, is there one? Do they, are they also fighter pilots? Oh my God. What are you watching? Like Top Gun? Is this like some Luke Skywalker and who's the other guy? Darth Vader? No, the other one. Yoda? Obi-Wan Kenobi? You can't just say the other one. There's so many. No, the one that- The Sith? Chewbacca? Leia? A human? Han Solo? Han Solo. Han Solo. He's not a Jedi. He can't use the force. He can't? No. He flies the Falcon. He's the fighter. He's
而且你开飞机？就像，你知道，飞行员吗？你是飞行员，战斗机飞行员吗？绝地武士是战斗机飞行员吗？绝地武士是能够引导原力并在战斗中使用原力的人。难道只有一个绝地武士吗？我气得五内俱焚。有那么多的绝地武士呢。我甚至不敢相信你会问：“只有一个吗？”他们，他们也是战斗机飞行员吗？天哪。你在看什么？像《壮志凌云》吗？这就像什么卢克·天行者和另外一个家伙是谁？达斯·维达？不，另一个。尤达？欧比旺·克诺比？你不能只说“另一个”。有那么多呢。不，那个——西斯？楚巴卡？莱娅？一个人类？汉·索洛？汉·索洛。汉·索洛。他不是绝地武士。他不会使用原力。他不会？不。他开“千年隼”号。他是战斗机飞行员。他是
the jet fighter. He's the pilot. He's, he's not a jet fighter. He's just a pilot. He's a scrappy fella. Is Luke Skywalker a Jedi? Yes. But he also drives a plane, right? He does drive a plane. He drives a plane. He does drive a plane. Okay. Yeah. So, so piloting the plane has nothing to do with it. It's not a prerequisite to being a Jedi. To everyone listening at home getting mad, I know. Is Princess Leia a Jedi? She can sense the force. She can reach out to Luke through it. She, they're like- Han Solo is not a Jedi as he has no, no ability to use the force. He can't use the force. How do you get the force? Do you have, do you have to become a Padawan? Well, you're, you're born with it and then your training helps you use it. So like Harry Potter, you're either
喷气式战斗机飞行员。他是飞行员。他不是喷气式战斗机飞行员。他只是个飞行员。他是个顽强的家伙。卢克·天行者是绝地武士吗？是的。但他他也开飞机，对吧？他确实开飞机。他开飞机。他确实开飞机。好吧。是的。所以，所以开飞机和这完全没关系。这不是成为绝地武士的先决条件。对于家里听得火冒三丈的听众们，我知道。莱娅公主是绝地武士吗？她能感知原力。她可以通过原力联系卢克。她，他们就像——汉·索洛不是绝地武士，因为他没有，没有使用原力的能力。他不会使用原力。你怎么获得原力？你必须，你必须成为学徒吗？好吧，你生来就有它，然后你的训练会帮助你使用它。就像《哈利·波特》一样，要么
born with magic or not. That's true. Yes. Okay. And then a Padawan would be like an apprentice with a Jedi who's a master, a master of the force. A master of harnessing the force. That's right. And a Padawan would learn how to like sort of tune into the force and use it. Is Chewbacca a Jedi? No, no. He doesn't have the force. No, no. Okay. I wish. Yeah, that would have been a great Jedi. Okay. Okay. Thank you. Where are we? So, well, D'Angelo is going to say that he's not interested in co-hosting these awards. He's not much of a performer. In fact, he's very, very bad. So, Michael's going to need to call a conference room meeting and everyone's going to try to coach D'Angelo on how to do banter and rat-a-tat-tat. Kevin has one of my favorite lines in the whole
天生有魔法，要么没有。确实如此。是的。好的。然后学徒就像是跟着一个作为绝地武士大师的师傅当学徒，绝地武士是原力的大师。精通驾驭原力的大师。没错。而学徒会学习如何调整自己去感应原力和使用它。楚巴卡是绝地武士吗？不，不。他没有原力。不，不。好吧。但愿是。是的，那会是个很棒的绝地武士。好吧。好吧。谢谢你们。我们说到哪了？所以，好吧，德安杰洛会说他对联合主持这些奖项不感兴趣。他不太是个表演者。事实上，他非常非常糟糕。所以，迈克尔需要召开一个会议室会议，每个人都试图指导德安杰洛如何进行幽默对话和快节奏的妙语连珠。凯文有我在这整集里
episode, which is, I love banter, but I hate witty banter. Well, D'Angelo's trying, but it turns out he's all rat-no-tat. Now, Michael's going to try all of these sort of wacky ways to get D'Angelo comfortable at hosting. We have an old tech alert, six minutes, four seconds. Is that a yellow Sony Walkman, like the waterproof one? Oh, yeah, that we all got, but mine never went in the water. I never took it in the water. No, it was just, it was not fully waterproof, but it was like water resistant because you needed that water resistance because you were going to sweat so hard while you were working out with that on. I see. Yeah. Also, the blow buttons used to pop off. Do you remember? They were like squishy puffy buttons and they would come off. It was super fun to take them off
最喜欢的台词之一，那就是：“我喜欢幽默对话，但我讨厌机智的幽默对话。”好吧，德安杰洛在努力，但事实证明他只有快节奏，没有妙语。现在，迈克尔将尝试所有这些古怪的方法来让德安杰洛在主持时感到自在。我们有一个旧科技警报，6分4秒。那是黄色的索尼随身听吗，就像防水的那款？哦，是的，我们都有的那款，但我从来没把它带进水里。我从没把它带进水里。不，它只是，它不是完全防水的，但它是防溅水的，因为你需要那种防水性能，因为当你戴着它锻炼时会大量出汗。我明白了。是的。而且气泡按钮过去常常会弹出来。你记得吗？它们就像是软乎乎的膨胀按钮，会掉下来。把它们拿下来超级有趣。
and put them back on. You know, before we move on, I did have a quick catch from the conference room scene at four minutes and 10 seconds, which is that Daryl is still rocking his Southwest style shirt. Oh, yeah. He's still trying to butter up to D'Angelo. He's going to have to forever, forever love it. Outside, Jim and Pam are strolling and they walk up and Aaron's in her car. She's eating in her car, eating lunch and she's like ducks down, like to hide. Yeah. And then she's like, get in, get in. And we find out that the reason that she's eating in her car is because she just needed to have a little alone time from Gabe. Yeah. She doesn't like him as it turns out. And Pam says maybe she should tell Gabe, you know, rather than waste more of his time.
然后重新穿上。你知道，在我们继续之前，我在四分十秒的会议室场景中发现了一个快速剪辑，那就是达里尔仍然穿着他的西南风格衬衫。哦，是的。他仍然在试图讨好德安吉洛。他将不得不永远、永远地喜欢它。在外面，吉姆和帕姆正在散步，他们走过去，艾伦在她的车里。她在车里吃东西，吃午饭，然后她像蹲下来，像是在躲藏。是的。然后她说，上车，上车。我们发现她之所以在车里吃东西，是因为她只是需要离盖伊远一点，享受一点独处的时间。是的。事实证明她不喜欢他。帕姆说也许她应该告诉盖伊，你知道的，而不是浪费他更多的时间。
Oh, Pam. Pam, Pam, Pam. This is, you cannot set up a real awkward moment for later. We had a question from Soyeon Jae from South Korea. Around six minutes and 30 seconds, there's a scene where Jim and Pam are walking down the street and find Aaron. Was the dialogue about sweet potato fries scripted or did you guys improvise? Well, I can tell you in the shooting draft, it said, Pam and Jim walk. They see Aaron sitting in her car. Aaron sees them and ducks down. They go to her window intrigued. So when I heard this dialogue and I saw this fan question, I had like one of those things like that memory just comes racing back into your head. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. I think this was John dunking on me. Really? Yeah.
哦，帕姆。帕姆，帕姆，帕姆。这是，你不能为以后制造一个真正的尴尬时刻。我们收到了来自韩国的 Soyeon Jae 的一个问题。在大约六分三十秒的时候，有一个场景是吉姆和帕姆走在街上找到了艾伦。关于红薯条的对话是剧本里的还是你们即兴发挥的？嗯，我可以告诉你，在拍摄初稿里写着，帕姆和吉姆在走。他们看到艾伦坐在她的车里。艾伦看到他们就蹲了下来。他们很感兴趣地走到她的车窗前。所以当我听到这段对话并看到这个粉丝的问题时，我脑子里闪过一种感觉，那种记忆就像赛车一样飞奔回你的脑海。哦，是的。哦，是的。我想这是约翰在拿我开涮。真的吗？是的。
Because. And I had this memory of him doing it and me laughing because I am pretty sure that I was going on and on about sweet potato fries and restaurants to him because I'm allergic to sweet potatoes and I was getting really frustrated that everywhere you went now, it was a sweet potato fry sweet potato fry. Why can't I just get a regular fry? And so I am pretty sure that he improvised that line because you had been going off about it. Yes. That's really funny. Because of this scene, I decided to do a deep dive on the sweet potato fry. Hit it, Sam. Hey everybody. We have a special treat at the Office Ladies Dundee Awards. Jenna, Jenna, Jenna, Jenna. Fisher, Fisher, Fisher is going to do a deep dive. Thank you so much.
因为。我记得他这么做过，而我在笑，因为我很确定我一直在跟他喋喋不休地谈论红薯条和餐厅，因为我对红薯过敏，而且我开始感到非常沮丧，无论你现在去哪里，到处都是红薯条，红薯条。为什么我不能只点普通的薯条？所以我很确定他即兴说出了那句台词，因为你一直在抱怨这个。是的。这真的很有趣。因为这个场景，我决定深入研究红薯条。放音乐，萨姆。大家好。我们在“办公室女士”邓迪奖上有一个特别节目。珍娜，珍娜，珍娜，珍娜。费舍尔，费舍尔，费舍尔要进行深度研究。非常感谢。
Thank you. Yes. The New York Times published an article in 2010 called sweet potatoes step out from under marshmallows. This was an article that was all about how sweet potatoes were making a huge comeback in restaurants and in recipes, in particular, the sweet potato fry. Here's what it said, quote, there is no denying that sweet potato fries are at the center of the sweet potato revolution. Wait, there's a sweet potato revolution? According to this article, there is. Oh my goodness. What began as innovation at the trendiest restaurants in San Francisco in New York in the 1980s has finally worked its way into the culinary mainstream. This article said that over the past two years, the number of restaurants offering sweet potatoes
谢谢。是的。《纽约时报》在2010年发表了一篇文章，题为《红薯从棉花糖下走出》。这是一篇关于红薯如何在餐馆和食谱中卷土重来的文章，特别是红薯条。它是这样写的，引述：“不可否认，红薯条是红薯革命的中心。”等等，还有一场红薯革命？根据这篇文章，确实有。噢，天哪。在上世纪80年代旧金山和纽约最时髦的餐厅里开始的创新，终于进入了烹饪主流。这篇文章说，在过去的两年里，提供红薯的餐馆数量
as a side dish had increased by 40%. 40%. And most of that was sweet potato fries. How about them apples? The article also cited that Google. New invention on the internet. Yes, at the time. Searches for sweet potato fries were up 40%. There's a number again. I know. That's sweeping the nation in increments of 40%. Yeah. I also learned from this article that in the United States, we harvest over 2 billion pounds of sweet potatoes each year, and that 47% of our nation's sweet potatoes are grown in North Carolina. Thanks, North Carolina. Yeah. I can't eat any of them, but that's cool. Finally, nutritionists love sweet potatoes because it is a vegetable that also has protein
作为配菜的比例增加了40%。40%。其中大部分是红薯条。你觉得这个怎么样？文章还引用了谷歌的话。互联网上的新发明。是的，在当时。搜索红薯条的人数增加了40%。又是一个数字。我知道。这正以40%的增幅席卷全国。是的。我还从这篇文章中了解到，在美国，我们每年收获超过20亿磅的红薯，我们国家47%的红薯都是在北卡罗来纳州种植的。谢谢你，北卡罗来纳州。是的。我一个都吃不了，但挺酷的。最后，营养学家很喜欢红薯，因为它是一种既含有蛋白质
and complex carbs that don't spike insulin levels. It is recommended for those with diabetes. And there you have it. That's why next year you're winning the best undie for deep dives. Yeah. Thank you so much. Thank you so much. Well, with that, you guys, let's take a break. We're going to be back because it's time. Sam, can you cut, swallow? For the Dundies, we'll be right back. The ceremony is going to begin with a video sketch, and it's starring D'Angelo and Michael. Oh, yeah. It's like those opening video sketches that they would do at the Emmys or something like that. D'Angelo is searching for Michael. And guess who's going to help him? Find Michael,
又含有不会使胰岛素水平飙升的复杂碳水化合物的蔬菜。它被推荐给糖尿病患者。这就是全部。这就是为什么明年你要赢得最佳深度研究邓迪奖。是的。非常感谢。非常感谢。好了，各位，我们休息一下。我们会回来的，因为时间到了。萨姆，你能剪掉，咽下去吗？为了邓迪奖，我们马上回来。典礼将以一个视频短剧开场，由德安吉洛和迈克尔主演。哦，是的。就像他们在艾美奖或其他类似活动上所做的那些开场视频短剧一样。德安吉洛正在寻找迈克尔。你猜谁来帮他？寻找迈克尔，
Michael, everyone in the office, all played by Michael Scott. That's right. First up is Joe Bennett. Michael is dressed as Joe. He has a wig. And he's getting some laughs, you guys. Yeah. It's actually a good video. Yeah. It's not bad. Then D'Angelo is going to go to accounting. He's looking for Michael. And guess who's going to help him? Michael Angela? Michael Angela. This bit gets a lot of laughs, in particular from Oscar. I want you to know there was a talking head in the shooting draft that would have come right after the scene in accounting. So D'Angelo says to Angela slash Michael, hey, can you help me find Michael Scott Angela? And Michael, as Angela answers, my boyfriend can. He's a state senator. Oh, wait, he can't because that title has
迈克尔，办公室里的每个人，全部由迈克尔·斯科特饰演。没错。首先是乔·本内特。迈克尔扮成乔的样子。他戴着假发。他逗大家笑呢，伙计们。是的。这其实是个好视频。是的。还不错。然后德安吉洛要去会计部。他在找迈克尔。你猜谁来帮他？迈克尔安琪拉？迈克尔安琪拉。这个笑话逗乐了很多人，特别是奥斯卡。我想让你们知道，拍摄初稿中有一个采访镜头，本来应该紧跟在会计部的场景之后。所以德安吉洛对安琪拉斜杠迈克尔说，嘿，你能帮我找迈克尔·斯科特吗？安琪拉和迈克尔作为安琪拉回答说，我男友可以。他是州参议员。哦，等等，他不能，因为这个头衔
no meaning. And then it cuts to Oscar and he is doubled over, right? Yes. Well, immediately after Oscar's laughter, it would have cut to him saying, I did some of the writing. That's fun. I know. That's very fun. Next up is Jim. And Michael's Jim is very funny. He has an earring. He does. And he's very slumped down. And yeah, you want to listen to some music? Then Michael is Phyllis. And he plays Phyllis so old and kind of like that commercial. Remember that commercial? I've fallen and I can't get up. Yes. Michael does that. In the shooting draft, Phyllis would have had a talking head after Michael's impression of her. Oh, I loved it. This is what she would have said. Look, I'm rich. I have a high profile marriage. People are going to take shots at me.
没有任何意义。然后镜头切到奥斯卡，他笑得直不起腰，对吧？是的。嗯，紧接着奥斯卡的笑声之后，镜头本该切到他说，我参与了一些剧本创作。这很有趣。我知道。这非常有趣。接下来是吉姆。迈克尔演的吉姆非常搞笑。他戴着耳环。他确实戴了。而且他驼着背。是的，你想听点音乐吗？然后迈克尔演菲利斯。他把菲利斯演得那么老，有点像那个广告。还记得那个广告吗？我摔倒了，爬不起来。是的。迈克尔就是这么演的。在拍摄初稿中，迈克尔模仿完菲利斯之后，菲利斯本该有一个独白镜头。哦，我太喜欢了。这就是她当时会说的话：听着，我有钱。我有一段备受瞩目的婚姻。人们会冲我来的。
Oh, Phyllis. This all ends with D'Angelo running into the bathroom. He's talking to himself. But guess what? When he looks in the mirror, Michael Scott has appeared. Well, we got a fan question about this mirror moment. I'm going to let Mindy take it away. One question that you have from a listener, Molly W from Eden Prairie, Minnesota. That sounds really idyllic. She said that one of my favorite movies growing up was the 2005 movie Bewitched. There's a scene in the movie where Will Ferrell is looking at the mirror and Steve Carell pops up beside the mirror as Uncle Arthur. And Molly's asking if in Michael's dundies the same thing happens where D'Angelo is looking in the mirror and Michael shows up inside. Was that a complete coincidence? Honestly, I think it is
哦，菲利斯。这一切以德安吉洛跑进洗手间结束。他自言自语。但你猜怎么着？当他照镜子时，迈克尔·斯科特出现了。好吧，我们收到了一个关于这个镜子时刻的粉丝问题。我要让敏迪来回答。一位听众莫莉·W（来自明尼苏达州伊甸草原）提出了一个问题。听起来真的很田园诗般。她说她成长过程中最喜欢的电影之一是2005年的电影《家有仙妻》（Bewitched）。电影中有一个场景，威尔·法瑞尔在照镜子，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔作为阿瑟叔叔突然出现在镜子旁边。莫莉问，在迈克尔的邓迪奖颁奖典礼上是否也发生了同样的事情，德安吉洛在照镜子，迈克尔出现在里面？这纯属巧合吗？老实说，我认为这
a complete coincidence. I did not see the Bewitched movie, although maybe I should. I think as a director, this is going to sound so corny. I think I wanted to do something with reflections because it's like a little bit tricky, but not too tricky. So I think that's why I did it as like a first time director. That reminded me of that advice that BJ Novak gave about directing when he came on the podcast. Remember, he said that advice that someone gave him is to just have one shot. One shot. That's interesting. One razzle dazzle. Yeah. Well, have you know that we shot all of these sequences for the video earlier in the week, so they were able to edit them together and we were really watching that up on the big screen. And Randy wanted to give a shout out to Chris Shadley,
纯属巧合。我没有看过《家有仙妻》这部电影，虽然也许我应该看。我想作为一名导演，这听起来太老套了。我想我只是想用倒影做点什么，因为它有点棘手，但又不是太棘手。所以我想这就是我作为一个新手导演这样做的原因。这让我想起了B·J·诺瓦克在播客中谈到导演时给出的建议。还记得吗，他说过别人给他的建议就是只拍一个镜头。一个镜头。这很有趣。一个炫目的镜头。是的。嗯，你知道吗，我们在这周早些时候为视频拍摄了所有这些序列，所以他们能够将它们剪辑在一起，我们真的在大大屏幕上观看了它。兰迪想向克里斯·沙德利致敬，
who was our playback technician. He was in charge of getting it all to playback on cue. I remember us watching that in real time, and I thought it was hilarious. And then when I rewatched this episode, I caught myself out of character laughing. Really? Yeah. Several times I'm just laughing. Brian, Brian too. We're like sitting next to each other. Well, we used to have to wait like a month before we would see our episodes on TV. And it was always fun when you got to see a little something put together. Yeah. It's time for the dundies to start. But D'Angelo can't do it. He's run to the bathroom. He's throwing up. Oh, yeah. Michael's really trying to convince him to go back on. He says, you got to do it for all those kids
他我们的播放技术员。他负责按时播放所有内容。我记得我们实时观看了那个节目，我觉得太搞笑了。然后当我重新观看这一集时，我发现自己脱离了角色在大笑。真的吗？是的。好几次我都笑出声来。布莱恩，布莱恩也是。我们就像坐在彼此旁边一样。嗯，以前我们得等上大约一个月才能在电视上看到我们的剧集。每当你看到一些拼凑在一起的东西时，总是很有趣。是的。邓迪奖要开始了。但德安吉洛办不到。他跑进洗手间。他在呕吐。哦，是的。迈克尔真的在试图说服他回去。他说，你得为了外面那些孩子们这么做
out there. We think this is really going to be a big speech. But then he says, you know, the kids eating from the kids menu. Like what? And then he's literally the kids out in the restaurant. And D'Angelo's like, I can't. And Michael's like, it's showtime. And he slaps him. And D'Angelo says, stop hitting me. They end up both slapping each other. And then they're ready to go. It's showtime. It's showtime. Mindy also had something to share with us about this scene. One of my favorite parts of any episode was in the injury when Michael needs help. But he's in the toilet. We can't even see him. And Steve is doing all this like audio comedy off camera in the bathroom. And so I think in this episode, when D'Angelo goes and throws up,
。我们以为这真的是一场宏大的演讲。但接着他说，你知道的，孩子们在儿童菜单上吃东西。就像什么？然后他真的是餐厅里的孩子们。德安吉洛说，我做不到。迈克尔说，演出时间到了。他打了德安吉洛一巴掌。德安吉洛说，别打我。他们最后互相扇耳光。然后他们准备好了。演出时间到。演出时间到。关于这个场景，敏迪也有话要跟我们分享。任何一集我最喜欢的片段之一是在《伤员》那一集里，迈克尔需要帮助。但他在厕所里。我们甚至看不到他。史蒂夫在洗手间外进行了各种音频喜剧表演。所以我认为在这一集里，当德安吉洛去呕吐时，
it's ridiculous to like people barfing so much. But on the office where we can't see anything, right? Because it's everything is mostly off camera. It's just, it's just fun sometimes to do that. Well, whatever happened in the bathroom, it worked. D'Angelo is going to take the stage. And they're going to start handing out awards. The first award is the best dad award. And it's going to go to Jim. Did you notice that the camera was positioned on Daryl? And then it goes to Jim? No, like in a real award show. Exactly. That's pretty great. Jim fails to thank Pam, the mother of his child, during his speech. And she has a little bit of sass about it. The next award is the best mom award. And much like you, Jenna, if there'd been a
看到人们呕吐那么多是很荒谬的，但在办公室里我们什么也看不到，对吧？因为一切基本都在镜头外。有时候这样做就是，就是很有趣。好吧，洗手间里发生的一切都奏效了。德安吉洛要登台了。他们要开始颁奖了。第一个奖项是最佳爸爸奖。将颁给吉姆。你注意到摄像机是对准达里尔的吗？然后才切到吉姆？不，就像在真正的颁奖典礼上一样。没错。太棒了。吉姆在演讲中没有感谢他孩子的母亲帕姆。她对此有点傲娇。下一个奖项是最佳妈妈奖。和你很像，珍娜，如果有
best deep dive award, you would have thought that was going to you. Pam thinks she's going to get best mom, but it's a Meredith. Yeah. One of my personal favorite pet myself on the back acting moments from the show is when they say the next award is going to be best mom. And Pam kind of like Shiley is preparing herself to win. There were a few awards we didn't see in this episode. They're in deleted scenes. And I think we should hear them. First up was Phyllis. Here is the Dundee that she got. The redefining beauty award goes to Phyllis Vance. This is for all the real women out there. Yeah. People get so behind Phyllis on that award, the whole place erupts. Then it's Angela's award. Let's hear what she got. This is very funny. This is a laugh riot. But you know what? I don't
最佳深度研究奖，你一定会觉得那是给你的。帕姆以为她会获得最佳妈妈，但那是梅雷迪思的。是的。剧中我个人最喜欢的自我肯定演技时刻之一是，当他们说下一个奖项将是最佳妈妈时，帕姆有点害羞地准备好获奖。这一集里有几个我们没看到的奖项。它们在被删减的片段里。我觉得我们应该听听看。首先是菲利斯。这是她得到的邓迪奖。重新定义美丽奖颁给菲利斯·万斯。这是给所有现实生活中的女性的。是的。人们非常支持菲利斯获得这个奖项，整个大厅都沸腾了。接下来是安琪拉的奖。让我们听听她得到了什么。这非常搞笑。这简直是一场笑剧。但你知道吗？我不在乎
care if you think I'm kind of a bitch. I'm also kind of dating a senator and kind of the happiest I've ever been. Yeah. Yes. You know, later in the episode, there's a reference to the kind of a bitch award. We never saw anybody win it. It was you. I kept my Dundee. I have both of mine. I have the tight ass award and I have kind of a bitch. And they sit up on my shelf right next to my Emmys and SAG awards. Pam does not get a Dundee in this episode. I was fascinated by that. Yeah. I read the shooting draft. Same. I was like, am I forgetting something? I went back to the shooting draft and it had the Dundee's pitch list and it had Jim Best Dad, Meredith Best Mom, Pam Best Kid. Oh. That would have been a funny picture. I mean, Michael did date her mom. I don't know.
你是否认为我有点刻薄。我也在和一位参议员约会，这可以说是我这辈子最开心的时候了。是的。是的。你知道，在这一集晚些时候，有一个对“有点刻薄奖”的引用。我们从未看到任何人赢得它。那就是你。我保留了我的邓迪奖。我有我的两个奖。我有“刻薄鬼”奖，我还有“有点刻薄奖”。它们就放在我的书架上，紧挨着我的艾美奖和演员工会奖。帕姆在本集中没有获得邓迪奖。我对此很着迷。是的。我读了拍摄初稿。我也是。我想，我是不是忘了什么？我回过头去看拍摄初稿，上面有邓迪奖的候选名单，上面写着吉姆：最佳爸爸，梅雷迪思：最佳妈妈，帕姆：最佳小孩。哦。那会是一张很有趣的照片。我的意思是，迈克尔确实和她的妈妈约会过。我不知道。
Well, we never shot that. I never had a moment with the Dundee's. It wasn't in the script. It was just on a pitch list. There was one that we did film that I wanted you to hear. It's Kelly's award. Let's hear that one. Oh, man. This has been such a good year for women in paper. Am I right? Come on, guys. Give ourselves a hand. Women in paper. This is pretty awesome. So I don't know why I'm up here and you're not. I don't know how I could have beaten you to get this, but I'm just going to take it. So thank you so much, you guys. This was part of the montage with Phyllis and Angela, but Kelly won the Women in Paper award. Wow. Mm-hmm. She's sorry you didn't win it. She's sorry. She, like, said that to everybody in the room. And then it's time for the hottest person in the
嗯，我们从来没拍过那个。我从来没有和邓迪奖有过交集。它不在剧本里。它只在候选名单上。我们确实拍过一个片段，我想让你听听。那是凯利的奖。我们听听那个。哦，天哪。对纸业女性来说，今年真是太棒了。我说的对吗？得了吧，伙计们。给自己鼓鼓掌。纸业女性。这太棒了。所以我不知道为什么我站在这里而你没有。我不知道我是怎么击败你拿到这个奖的，但我打算收下它。非常感谢你们，伙计们。这是与菲利斯和安琪拉蒙太奇剪辑的一部分，但凯利赢得了纸业女性奖。哇。嗯哼。她很遗憾你没有获奖。她很遗憾。她，就像，对房间里的每个人都这么说了。然后轮到办公室里
office. Ryan thinks it's going to be him. Again? Nope. Who's it going to be? It's Danny Cordray, everybody. Yeah, but I'm so sorry he couldn't attend tonight, but don't worry. Michael took the camera crew to his house. It's in deleted scenes. Let's hear part of it. Hottest in the office goes to Danny Cordray. Danny could not be here tonight to accept his award, so he is live via satellite. Oh, Danny, are you there? Hey, you guys. I wish I could be there in person to accept this Dundee award. Michael came to my house and gave it to me in person. Look, there he is. Hey, everybody. Hey, Michael. Hey. It's very nice of you, really. Where are you going to put that? I don't know. I think you should put it right here on the piano. Wow. Isn't he good-looking? Yeah. That's... Look at him. Look at how good-looking that guy is. It's already pretty embarrassing, Michael. No way. Anyway, I appreciate you stopping by. A studs, I have to say, together. What are you doing for the rest of the day? Yeah. It is. It is so awkward. And then Dwight goes, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye.
最性感的人了。瑞恩以为会是他。又来？不。会是谁呢？是丹尼·科德雷，各位。是的，但我很遗憾他今晚不能出席，但别担心。迈克尔带着摄制组去了他家。它在被删减的片段中。我们听听其中的一部分。办公室最性感奖颁给丹尼·科德雷。丹尼今晚无法来到现场领奖，所以他通过卫星连线直播。哦，丹尼，你在吗？嘿，伙计们。我希望我能亲自到场接受这个邓迪奖。迈克尔来到我家，亲自把它交给了我。看，他在那儿。嘿，大家好。嘿，迈克尔。嘿。你太好了，真的。你打算把这个放在哪里？我不知道。我想你应该把它放在钢琴上。哇。他长得不是很帅吗？是的。那是……看看他。看看那家伙长得多帅。这已经够尴尬了，迈克尔。才不呢。不管怎样，谢谢你顺道过来。说实话，两个帅哥聚在一起。你今天剩下的时间打算干什么？是的。确实如此。这太尴尬了。然后德怀特说，再见，再见，再见，再见，再见，再见。
Next up, Stanley is going to be presented with the Diabetes Award. And Phyllis has my favorite talking head. I love it so much. And she's like, you know, I have diabetes, too, but you don't see me making a big deal about it. So much Phyllis-ass. I know. It's like they're friends, but there's so much competition there. Stanley and Phyllis are frenemies. They are true frenemies. Well, during all of these awards in the shooting draft, Michael goes over to check on Dwight. And Dwight's really starting to unravel. It's also in deleted scenes. It's going pretty well. Same crop, different dundies. Yeah, D'Angelo's great, but he's a little green. I need you to keep an eye on him in the future there. You can count on me. That's what I do. Keep the boss on track. Thank you, Dwight. Yes, master. You're welcome, master. Anything for you, master. Michael's like, uh, okay. Yikes. Yeah. And then next up, Salt in the Wound, Dwight wins the Promising Assistant Manager Award and tosses it right in the trash. Yeah, I don't know if you noticed during the scene at 13 minutes and 17 seconds, Aaron is holding up a cue card. Yeah. And if you read the cue card, Dwight's last name is spelled S-H-R-U-T-E. Instead of S-C-H. Yeah. When this episode aired, fans pointed this out. They wanted to know why. Well, the reason it was written that way is because that is how it was scripted. But it was not intended as a joke. You know, Mindy wrote this episode and she revealed that that is how she spells shrewt. And this reveal from Mindy began a hilarious snarky text exchange between Mindy Kaling and Mike Schur. Mindy said, I have spelled it shrewt, S-H-R-U-T-E, in every single script I've written since Hot Girl. Have I been wrong this whole time? That's what she tweeted.
接下来，斯坦利将被授予糖尿病奖。菲利斯有我最喜欢的独白。我太喜欢了。她说，你知道，我也有糖尿病，但你看不到我把它当成大惊小怪的事情。满满的菲利斯式傲娇。我知道。就像他们是朋友，但其中有这么多的竞争。斯坦利和菲利斯是亦敌亦友。他们是真正的亦敌亦友。嗯，在拍摄初稿的所有这些颁奖过程中，迈克尔过去查看德怀特的情况。德怀特真的开始崩溃了。这也是被删减的片段。进展相当顺利。同样的庄稼，不同的邓迪奖。是的，德安吉洛很棒，但他有点初出茅庐。我需要你以后盯着他点。你可以指望我。这就是我所做的。让老板步入正轨。谢谢你，德怀特。遵命，主人。不客气，主人。为了你，主人，赴汤蹈火。迈克尔心想，呃，好吧。哎呀。是的。然后接下来，雪上加霜，德怀特赢得了极有前途的助理经理奖，并直接把它扔进了垃圾桶。是的，我不知道你是否注意到在13分17秒的场景中，艾伦举着一张提示卡。是的。如果你读一下提示卡，德怀特的姓氏拼写是S-H-R-U-T-E。而不是S-C-H。是的。当这一集播出时，粉丝们指出了这一点。他们想知道为什么。嗯，这样写的原因是剧本就是这么写的。但它并不是作为一个笑话设计的。你知道，敏迪写了这一集，她透露这就是她拼写“舒特”（shrewt）的方式。敏迪的这个揭秘引发了敏迪·卡灵和迈克·舒尔之间一段搞笑而刻薄的短信交流。敏迪说，自从《辣妹》（Hot Girl）以来，我在我写过的每一个剧本里都是把它拼成shrewt，S-H-R-U-T-E。难道我这一直都拼错了吗？这就是她在推特上发的。
And Mike Schur wrote back, yes. S-C-H-R-U-T-E. Don't worry, it's not like you've been writing lines for that character since 2004. Damn. And Mindy wrote back, this is legit mortifying. I guess you have a leg up on its spelling because you're in the shrewt clan. To which Mike replied, I also have a leg up on it because I saw the way it was spelled in the pilot and then continued to spell it that way. Hashtag burn. Note to self to not get in an argument with Mike Schur. I know. Oh my lord. Yeah. But if you go to 13 minutes, 17 seconds, you can see it right there on the cue card. It's funny to me that the people writing the cue card didn't question it in any way. They didn't say, hey Mindy, did you mean this? Yeah. They were just like, no, this is what the script says, so I'm going to do it. Next up, Erin is going to win Cutis Redhead in the office and Meredith is pissed off. She throws her best mom trophy on the ground. She would rather be Cutis Redhead than a great mom. Interesting. Erin is going to go up to receive her award. She is so genuinely delighted. She's never won an award in her life.
迈克·舒尔回信说，是的。S-C-H-R-U-T-E。别担心，又不是说你从2004年开始就一直在为那个角色写台词。该死。敏迪回信说，这简直太丢脸了。我猜你在拼写上占了便宜，因为你是舒特家族的一员。对此，迈克回复说，我在拼写上也占了便宜，因为我看到试播集中就是这么拼的，然后就一直那么拼。话题标签：扎心。自我提醒：不要和迈克·舒尔争论。我知道。哦，天哪。是的。但如果你去到13分17秒，你就能直接在提示卡上看到它。我觉得很有趣的是，写提示卡的人根本没有对此产生任何疑问。他们没有说，嘿，敏迪，你是这个意思吗？是的。他们只是觉得，不，这就是剧本上写的，所以我就这么做。接下来，艾伦将赢得办公室最可爱红发女郎奖，而梅雷迪思气坏了。她把她的最佳妈妈奖杯扔在了地上。她宁愿当最可爱红发女郎也不愿当伟大的妈妈。有趣的是。艾伦要上去领奖了。她真是由衷的高兴。她这辈子从来没得过奖。
Yeah, she says, you know, it's true what they said. The dundies are magical, but I don't feel it because I don't think we should be together. Yeah, she's with the wrong person. For her, the awards have become this truth serum and she is going to break up with Gabe in front of everybody. And then Gabe goes up on stage so odd. Why doesn't he just leave? I was very curious about this, so I went to the shooting draft. Okay. He's going to respond to Erin's breakup also on the microphone publicly. And D'Angelo says to him, since you're up here anyway, do you want your dundie? It's the Ichabod Crane Award. Sorry, that made me laugh out loud. So I don't know if the whole reason they brought him up on stage was for that dundie joke, but then it didn't make it in.
是的，她说，你知道，他们说的是真的。邓迪奖是神奇的，但我没有这种感觉，因为我认为我们不应该在一起。是的，她和不对的人在一起了。对她来说，这些奖项已经变成了这种测谎血清，她要在所有人面前和盖伊分手。然后盖伊上了台，太奇怪了。他为什么不直接离开？我对这个很好奇，所以我去看了拍摄初稿。好吧。他也要在麦克风前公开回应艾伦的分手。德安吉洛对他说，既然你反正都在这儿，你想要你的邓迪奖吗？这是伊卡博德·克瑞恩奖。抱歉，这让我大声笑了出来。所以我不知道他们把他请上台的全部原因是不是为了那个邓迪奖的笑话，但后来并没有被剪进去。
Things are going to get more awkward rather than less awkward when Michael presents the award to D'Angelo for best dundies host. Oh man, we're Dwight. I know Dwight is so hurt and then in order to make his speech, D'Angelo has to put on the Walkman and then he's screaming. The manager of the restaurant has had it. First, Kevin is coloring on the tablecloth. Then they talked about STDs and now he's just screaming into the microphone. Yeah, he's going to throw everyone out. The manager was played by Bill Coleus and according to his bio, he has also appeared in the Marvelous Mrs. Maisel, Criminal Minds and over 50 national commercials. Wow.
当迈克尔把最佳邓迪奖主持人奖颁给德安吉洛时，事情变得更加尴尬而不是不那么尴尬。哦，天哪，我们德怀特。我知道德怀特太受伤了，然后为了发表获奖感言，德安吉洛不得不戴上随身听，然后他在尖叫。餐厅经理受够了。首先，凯文在桌布上涂鸦。然后他们谈论了性传播疾病，现在他只是对着麦克风尖叫。是的，他要把所有人都赶出去。经理是由比尔·科利斯饰演的，根据他的简历，他还出演过《了不起的麦瑟尔夫人》、《犯罪心理》和50多个国家级广告。哇。
Plus, he says in his bio that the commercials have allowed him to visit Buenos Aires, hang out with James Gandolfini and get naked on 43rd Street. What ad was that? Don't know, it didn't say. Everyone is now just sort of milling about outside. 16 minutes, 50 seconds. In the background of Michael's talking head, did anyone else catch that Paul and Rain and Will were talking and Rain motions to Will that he has something in the corner of his mouth? I don't know if it's food or what. And then immediately Will wipes off his mouth. Did anyone catch it? How about Justine Y from San Francisco, California?
另外，他在简历中说，这些广告让他去过布宜诺斯艾利斯，和詹姆斯·甘多菲尼一起闲逛，还在43rd街赤身裸体。那是哪支广告？不知道，上面没写。现在大家只是在外面闲逛。16分50秒。在迈克尔的独白背景中，有没有人注意到保罗、雷恩和威尔在说话，雷恩示意威尔他嘴角有东西？我不知道是食物还是什么。然后威尔立刻擦了嘴。有人注意到吗？来自加利福尼亚州旧金山的茹斯甸·Y呢？
Yes, Justine. She wrote in that exact background catch. Now Pam is going to approach Michael and suggest that they all grab some ice cream and go back to the office and keep the night going. And what's in her hand, Jenna? It's so weird. It's a Dundee. Is she carrying Jim's best dad Dundee? I could not. This threw me off. This is what made me obsessed with trying to figure out if my memory was wrong. And Pam had won a Dundee. There is no way that Michael Scott didn't give Pam a Dundee. There is no way. Well, it's not in the script. We never shot it. I kept both of my Dundies. I can promise you, if I had been given a Dundee that night, I would have it.
是的，茹斯甸。她写信提到了那个确切的背景镜头。现在帕姆要走近迈克尔，建议他们去买点冰淇淋，然后回办公室继续狂欢。她手里拿的是什么，珍娜？太奇怪了。是一个邓迪奖。她拿着吉姆的最佳爸爸邓迪奖吗？我简直不敢相信。这把我弄糊涂了。这就是为什么我执着于试图弄清楚我的记忆是否错误。而且帕姆赢得过一个邓迪奖。迈克尔·斯科特不可能不给帕姆颁发一个邓迪奖。这是绝对不可能的。嗯，剧本里没有。我们从来没拍过。我保留了我的两个邓迪奖。我可以向你保证，如果那天晚上我拿到了一个邓迪奖，我一定会留着它。
We kept all of our Dundies. Of course. We got to take them home with us. On the way back to Dunder Mifflin, I guess D'Angelo really had to pee. Anyone to use the bathroom, but Michael was like, no, it's close. Just get in the car. They're not going to get seats together in the conference room if they don't leave now. Yeah. And Dwight just starts to go off. He goes off on D'Angelo. He goes off on the Dundies, what people wore, that the awards were stupid, and Michael is ticked off. Yeah. They get in a pretty big argument and then Dwight gets out of the car and runs away. Well, when everyone is walking in, you can see that Ryan has a Dundee in his hand. Now, I do remember he really did win a Dundee. We just, it got cut.
我们保留了我们所有的邓迪奖。当然。我们把它们带回家了。在回邓德·米夫林的路上，我想德安吉洛一定急着想上厕所。任何人都可以用洗手间，但迈克尔说，不，很近了。上车吧。如果他们现在不离开，他们在会议室里就坐不到一起了。是的。德怀特开始发飙了。他对德安吉洛发飙。他对邓迪奖发飙，对人们穿的衣服发飙，说这些奖项很蠢，而迈克尔被激怒了。是的。他们发生了相当激烈的争吵，然后德怀特下了车，跑开了。嗯，当每个人走进来时，你可以看到瑞恩手里拿了一个邓迪奖。现在，我确实记得他真的赢得了邓迪奖。我们只是，它被剪掉了。
Yeah. In the shooting draft, it says that Ryan wins the most classically handsome Dundee. Yes. And he's very pleased with that. Once we get in the conference room, Daryl has set up a keyboard in the corner and two awards are given in the conference room. One was in the shooting draft. We also filmed it. It's in deleted scenes. Daryl would have won the Moving On Up Award. And then Michael is going to present Andy with the Doobie Doobie Pothead Stoner of the Year Award because he tried pot in college. And oh boy, this kicks off a moment. Does it ever? Andy accepts and he tells Michael, thank you. And then he says, no, thank you for everything.
是的。在拍摄初稿中，写着瑞恩赢得了最具古典英俊邓迪奖。是的。他对此非常满意。一进会议室，达里尔就在角落里架起了一架电子琴，会议室里颁发了两个奖项。其中一个在拍摄初稿中。我们也拍了。它在被删减的片段中。达里尔本该赢得“步步高升奖”。然后迈克尔将把“年度杜比杜比瘾君子 Stoner 奖”颁给安迪，因为他在大学里尝试过大麻。哦，天哪，这引发了一个时刻。可不是吗？安迪接受了奖项，他告诉迈克尔，谢谢你。然后他说，不，谢谢你所做的一切。
Did you hear Ed's voice crack? I did. Yeah. That's just real emotion. Yeah. If you go to 18 minutes 53 seconds, he's emotional because he knows what's coming. Music is going to start playing and everyone in the conference room is going to sing a tribute song to Michael. We are going to sing a version of Seasons of Love from the musical Rent. So Jenna, right as the music starts, there would have been a cutaway Jim and Pam double talking head. And I wanted to share it with you. Jim says, we practiced every day after work in the warehouse.
你听到埃德的声音破音了吗？我听到了。是的。那只是真实的感情。是的。如果你去到18分53秒，他情绪激动，因为他知道接下来会发生什么。音乐要开始播放了，会议室里的每个人都要为迈克尔唱一首致敬歌曲。我们要唱一首音乐剧《吉屋出租》（Rent）中的《爱的季节》（Seasons of Love）的版本。所以珍娜，就在音乐响起的那一刻，本来会有一个吉姆和帕姆的双人采访镜头的切换，我想跟你分享一下。吉姆说，我们在仓库里每天下班后都练习。
And Pam says, we just thought it would be a nice thing to do. And then it would cut back and everyone would start to sing. Well, we practiced a lot as a cast for this moment. And Angela, you thought we should hear this. I do. I mean, my memory was just, it was so special to us. You know, Phyllis and I had to sing together. Email Fords, you made us read. I remember. And we would meet in my trailer and practice. Email Fords, you made us read. It's a lot.
帕姆说，我们只是觉得这样做会是一件美好的事。然后镜头会切回来，大家开始唱歌。嗯，作为演员，我们为这一刻排练了很多次，安琪拉，你觉得我们应该听听这个。我确实这么认为。我的记忆是，这真的对我们太特别了。你知道，菲利斯和我不得不一起唱歌。电子邮件表格，你让我们读的。我记得。我们会在我的房车里见面练习。电子邮件表格，你让我们读的。这太多了。
We all got like a digital file with the music and we would do that. We would just sing our little phrase and practice and practice and practice. And because Phyllis and I had to do ours together, we would meet in practice. Well, we got a fan mail flurry. People wanted to know, is it true that the Seasons of Love parody, the office sings for Michael in this episode was actually a surprise for Steve Carell? So yes, it was. Yes and no. This story has gotten embellished. So the truth is Steve knew this song existed.
我们都得到了一个带有音乐的数字文件，我们会那样做。我们只会唱我们的小乐段，然后练习、练习、练习。因为菲利斯和我必须一起完成我们的部分，我们会聚在一起练习。嗯，我们收到了大量的粉丝信件。人们想知道，这首歌是真的吗，《爱的季节》恶搞版，办公室里的大家在这集里为迈克尔唱的这首歌，实际上是给史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的一个惊喜？所以是的，确实是。是的，也是也不是。这个故事被夸大了。所以事实是史蒂夫知道这首歌的存在。
It was in the shooting draft. It was part of the table read. But we practiced it privately. He was never part of any rehearsals. So the first time he heard us sing together was in that room on the first take. We even did our on-camera rehearsals without him. Yeah. So what you see in Steve's face, his emotion. I mean, yes, he's a great actor, but also Steve, our friend, was watching all of our hard work and just us showing him how much we loved him and we're going to miss him. When I look at Steve's face in that scene, I see a person who's really in the moment
它在拍摄初稿中。它是围读剧本的一部分。但我们是私下排练的。他从未参与过任何排练。所以他第一次听到我们一起唱歌是在那个房间的第一条拍摄中。我们甚至在没有他的情况下进行了镜头前排练。是的。所以你在史蒂夫脸上的表情中看到的，是他的情绪。我的意思是，是的，他是一个伟大的演员，但也是史蒂夫，我们的朋友，在看着我们所有的努力工作，只是向他展示我们是多么爱他，我们有多么想念他。当我看着那一幕中史蒂夫的脸时，我看到的是一个真正沉浸在当下的人，
who is taking in everything he's about to leave behind. Yeah. And I think he was feeling that in the moment. I've actually talked to him about it and he said it was incredibly moving. Yeah. And we all tear up. In fact, Phyllis and I held hands for part of it. I just think we need to hear it. Oh my God, something's happening.
他在吸收他即将抛下的所有东西。是的。我认为他当时确实有这种感觉。我其实和他谈过这件事，他说这极其感人。是的。我们都流泪了。事实上，菲利斯和我有一部分时间手拉着手。我只是觉得我们需要听听看。哦，天哪，有事情要发生了。
9,986,000 minutes. We actually sat down and did the math. 9,986,000 minutes. That's how many minutes that you've worked here. In costumes. And impressions. In meetings. In cups of coffee.
998.6万分钟。我们真的坐下来算了算。998.6万分钟。这就是你在这里工作的分钟数。在服装中。在模仿中。在会议中。在几杯咖啡中。
For birthdays. More meetings. Email Fords, you made us read. 9,986,000 minutes. That's like watching Die Hard 80,000 times. You hit me with your car. You helped me get off drugs. I watch you when you sleep.
为了生日。更多的会议。电子邮件表格，你让我们读的。998.6万分钟。就像看8万次《虎胆龙威》。你开车撞了我。你帮我戒了毒。我看着你睡觉。
I forgive you for kissing me. Remember to call. Remember to call. Remember to call. Measure. Measure your love and love. Remember to call. Remember to call.
我原谅你吻了我。记得打电话。记得打电话。记得打电话。衡量。衡量你的爱与爱。记得打电话。记得打电话。
So sweet. I love it. Every time. I just love it. I want you guys to know in the shooting draft, right after D'Angelo hits that super high note, there was a talking head written for him where he would have said, I'm not a good performer, but I can sing like a f***ing angel. Well, we got a lot of fan mail flurries about this song, Angela.
太甜了。我喜欢。每次。我只是喜欢它。我想让你们知道，在拍摄初稿中，就在德安吉洛唱出那个超高音之后，为他写了一段独白，他本会说，我不是个好表演者，但我能像他妈的天使一样唱歌。嗯，关于这首歌，我们收到了很多粉丝来信，安琪拉。
And one of the biggest was something I did not notice until I read our mail. I don't know how I missed it. I think I was just overcome with emotion. But fans pointed out that Rainn Wilson as Dwight was not in the scene. It's crazy to think about. Yeah. And they said, we get why he wasn't in the scene. It's because in the scene prior, he gets mad.
其中最大的一点是我在读我们的信之前没有注意到的。我不知道我是怎么漏掉的。我想我只是被情感淹没了。但粉丝们指出，饰演德怀特的雷恩·威尔逊并没有出现在这个场景中。想起来太疯狂了。是的。他们说，我们理解他为什么不在这个场景中。那是因为在之前的场景中，他生气了。
He gets out of the car. People said considering how monumental a scene this was for both the show and the cast, it really feels like he is missing. A lot of people felt that it should have been Dwight standing next to Michael instead of D'Angelo. And people were hoping maybe Mindy could make sense of this. And here's what she had to say. This is a question that you said a lot of people sent in, which was why wasn't Rainn a part of the song?
他下车了。人们说，考虑到这对剧集和演员阵容来说是多么具有里程碑意义的一个场景，他真的感觉像是缺席了。很多人觉得应该站在迈克尔旁边的是德怀特而不是德安吉洛。人们希望也许敏迪能对此做出解释。以下是她的说法。这是一个你说的很多人发信来问的问题，那就是为什么雷恩不参与这首歌？
We know why Dwight wasn't in the scene. In the scene prior, he stormed out of the car. So it would make sense he wasn't there. But considering how monumental a scene this was for both the show and the cast, it really feels like he's missing. And so I have to say, I think this is a taste thing. I think that if it didn't make sense emotionally in the episode for him to be there, and I think that orchestrating it so that Dwight would be there when it didn't make sense for his character
我们知道为什么德怀特不在这个场景中。在之前的场景中，他气冲冲地走出了车。所以他不在那里是说得通的。但考虑到这对剧集和演员阵容来说是多么具有里程碑意义的一个场景，他真的感觉像是缺席了。所以我必须说，我认为这是一种品味问题。我认为如果在剧集中从情感上来说他出现在那里并说不通，而且我认为刻意安排德怀特出现在那里而对他的角色来说又说不通
would have, I think, been a bridge too far. It did feel like emotionally it's like what the cast, the actors, and also the characters sort of wanted to express. And we know that Steve is so good when Michael's emotional. He's like and gets touched. And it just felt like it was nearing the end. So it needed to happen. But that's my answer to that.
的话，我认为，那就有点太牵强了。确实感觉从情感上讲，这就像是演员们，还有角色们某种程度上想要表达的。我们知道史蒂夫在迈克尔情绪激动时表现得非常好。他就像是会被触动。而且感觉它已经接近尾声了。所以它必须发生。但这就是我对这个问题的回答。
Well, we were really curious what it must have been like to direct such a huge moment. And we asked Mindy about it. Here's what she had to say. It is so hard to direct an emotional goodbye like this so much harder than directing a fight or even people kissing or romance and obviously harder, anything harder than comedy because in comedy you kind of know when you have a scene. But in something emotional when everyone's coming together just saying, it's very hard to give notes because if it, if everyone is like feeling it so emotionally
嗯，我们很好奇导演这样一个宏大的时刻会是什么感觉。我们向敏迪询问了这件事。以下是她的说法：导演这样一场充满情感的告别真的太难了，比导演一场打斗甚至人们亲吻或浪漫要难得多，显然比任何事情都难，比喜剧更难，因为在喜剧中，你多少知道你什么时候拍好了一个场景。但在某种情感化的场景中，当每个人都聚集在一起说，给出指导意见非常难，因为如果，如果每个人都深深地沉浸在情感中
and then you have a lot of notes, people kind of don't want to hear it. They're like, don't be a drag. We're all like in our feelings. And so that was, I think, one of the unique challenges of this episode. I hear that. Yeah. I also know as a cast, we were so gutted and we were in our feelings. We were.
然后你有很多意见，大家其实不太想听。他们会说，别扫兴。我们都沉浸在情绪里。所以我想这是这一集独特的挑战之一。我懂的。是的。我也知道作为演员，我们都心碎了，我们都沉浸在情绪中。我们确实是。
Yeah. We got one final fan mail flurry about this scene. People wanted to know who wrote the song. Well, Mindy wrote the lyrics and Randy said that Eve Nelson, our go-to composer created that instrumental track that we sang along to. And we paid a royalty fee of $25,000 for the rights to the music. And people also wanted to know, is that an accurate number of minutes that Michael would have worked in the office
是的。关于这个场景，我们收到了最后一封粉丝来信。人们想知道这首歌是谁写的。嗯，敏迪写了歌词，兰迪说我们的御用作曲家伊芙·纳尔逊创作了我们随之合唱的器乐音轨。我们支付了25,000美元的版权费来获得音乐版权。人们还想知道，迈克尔在办公室工作的分钟数是一个准确的数字，
or was it the number of minutes that Steve worked on the show? Well, Angie got out my calculator. You did the math. I did. So what I did was I counted all the episodes that Steve has been in and I assumed that we, on average, we work about 60 hours a week per episode. So I added all that up and did the minutes and I can tell you, it's not the number of minutes that Steve worked on the show.
还是史蒂夫在节目中工作的分钟数？嗯，安吉拿出了我的计算器。你算了一下。我算过了。所以我所做的就是数了数史蒂夫参演的所有集数，我假设我们平均每集每周工作大约60个小时。所以我把所有这些加起来，算出了分钟数，我可以告诉你，这不是史蒂夫在节目中工作的分钟数。
It wasn't enough minutes. So I'm going with the answer is it's the number of minutes Michael has worked at Dunder Mifflin, because also Michael has worked at Dunder Mifflin more than seven years, which is how long Steve worked on the show. I hope that clears things up for everyone. It was about 10 minutes of math. I was going to say, how long did it take you to come to your conclusion?
分钟数不够。所以我倾向于认为这个答案是迈克尔在邓德·米夫林工作的分钟数，因为迈克尔在邓德·米夫林工作的时间也超过了七年，也就是史蒂夫在节目中工作的时间。我希望这能为所有人解开谜团。这大概花了10分钟的计算。我正想说，你得出结论花了多长时间？
About 10 minutes. I mean, because I was trying to figure out a lot of things I had to. You had to. Count episodes and I would say that's impressive. I think it would have taken me longer than 10 minutes. Maybe I'll get a Dundee for best calculator work. Yes. Next year you'll have to see.
大约10分钟。我的意思是，因为我在试图弄清楚很多事情，我必须这样做。你必须这样做。数集数，我会说这很厉害。我想我花的时间会超过10分钟。也许我会因为最佳计算器工作而赢得一个邓迪奖。是的。明年你得拭目以待了。
I'm on the edge of my seat. Well, the episode is going to end with a tag. It's a flashback to earlier in the evening, because Toby is going to win the extreme repulsiveness award. D'Angelo is reading the cue card. He's like, wait, what am I? He's like, what am I even kind of mean? Toby doesn't want to go accept it.
我拭目以待。嗯，这一集将在一个彩蛋中结束。这是对当晚早些时候的一个闪回，因为托比将赢得极端令人厌恶奖。德安吉洛正在读提示卡。他说，等等，什么？我是什么？他说，我甚至有点刻薄是什么意思？托比不想去领奖。
But Oscar's like, it's his last Dundee's man. He got to play along. Yeah. And he's going to use his acceptance speech to come clean about the Scranton Strangler case for which he was a juror and they found this person guilty and he's been given the death penalty we find out. Toby's now not so sure that guy really did it. And that's how it ends.
但奥斯卡说，这是他最后一个邓迪奖了，伙计。他得配合演出。是的。他将利用他的获奖感言来澄清斯克兰顿扼喉手案，他是该案的陪审员，他们裁定此人有罪，我们发现他被判处死刑。托比现在不太确定那家伙真的是凶手。事情就是这样结束的。
Yeah. It almost ends like mid-sentence. Yeah. Like when I was watching it, I was like, wait, wait, that's it? Well, that was Michael's last Dundee's. I've got a few extra tidbits here for the end of the episode. I didn't know where to put this information. So I'll tell it to you now.
是的。它几乎像是在半句话中结束了。是的。就像我在看的时候，我想，等等，等等，就这样？好吧，那是迈克尔的最后一个邓迪奖。我在这一集的结尾还有一些额外的花絮。我不知道把这些信息放在哪里。所以我现在就告诉你。
Hmm. This episode was originally titled Goodbye, Michael Part One. But it was renamed and given a new release date when NBC announced that Goodbye, Michael, Steve's actual final episode could be a super-sized episode. So then this became Michael's last Dundee's. But the original Goodbye to Steve Carell on our show was going to be Dundee's that flowed into Goodbye, Michael. Yeah.
嗯。这一集最初名为《再见，迈克尔第一部分》（Goodbye, Michael Part One）。但当NBC宣布《再见，迈克尔》（史蒂夫真正的最后一集）可以成为一个超长集时，它被重新命名并给出了新的上映日期。所以这成了《迈克尔的最后一个邓迪奖》。但我们节目中对史蒂夫·卡瑞尔最初的告别本来是融入《再见，迈克尔》的邓迪奖。是的。
My gosh, we're literally speaking in unison. I also thought you might be wondering what Miles McNutt thought about this episode. I have to tell you, from the very beginning of the episode, when you did Fast Facts, I thought for sure one of your Fast Facts was going to be what Miles McNutt thought of it. I have been waiting this whole episode. I can't wait to hear. It was going to be. It was.
天哪，我们简直是异口同声。我还以为你在想迈尔斯·麦克纳特对这集是怎么看的。我得告诉你，从这集一开始，当你讲“快速事实”时，我敢肯定你的其中一个“快速事实”会是迈尔斯·麦克纳特对它的看法。我整集都在等待。我迫不及待想听。本来是的，确实是。
But then yesterday, you asked me if you could have Fast Facts number three. So I had to move this information to the end of the episode. But I was not going to leave you hanging. Trust me, Miles McNutt gave it a B minus. B minus. He said he really liked the cold open and the closing song. But a lot of his review focused on comparing the two Dundee episodes. And he felt that the first one was superior.
但昨天你问我能不能占用第三个“快速事实”。所以我不得不把这个信息移到节目的最后。但我不会让你悬着不管的。相信我，迈尔斯·麦克纳特给它打了B减。B减。他说他真的很喜欢开场和结尾的歌。但他的很多评论都集中在比较这两集邓迪奖上。他觉得第一集更好。
And it was very hard to live in its shadow in Miles' estimation. Miles, so much more is happening in this episode than in the first Dundee's. Your lead character is leaving the show. You have a lot of ground to cover. Miles, I think you're being too harsh. I will end this with a letter from Autumn B in Wisconsin who said, Incredible women of office ladies. Thank you.
在迈尔斯看来，活在它的阴影下非常艰难。迈尔斯，这一集发生的事情比第一集邓迪奖要多得多。你的主角要离开剧组了。你要讲的内容很多。迈尔斯，我觉得你太严厉了。我要用威斯康星州奥特姆·B的一封信来结束：“办公室女士们的杰出女性们。谢谢你们。”
Thank you, Autumn. After watching Michael's last Dundee's, I watched the first one. Please, please do this. Watching these two episodes back to back illuminates the evolution of Michael Scott. A man yearning for belonging and acceptance becomes a man who has found his place, his confidence, his people, and his purpose. The contrast between the first and the last Dundee's brings hope and comfort to all of us who believe that with time and conviction, we will become better versions of ourselves and live our best lives.
谢谢你，奥特姆。看了迈尔斯最后的邓迪奖后，我看了第一集。求求你们，一定要这样做。连续观看这两集，展现了迈尔斯·斯科特的演变。一个渴望归属感和接纳的男人，变成了一个找到了自己的位置、自信、伙伴和目标的男人。第一届和最后一届邓迪奖之间的对比，给所有相信只要有时间和信念，我们就能成为更好的自己、过上最好生活的人带来了希望和安慰。
Of all people, it was Michael Scott who would have thought. Take that, Miles McNutt. That's what I'm saying. Go, Autumn. I think you cannot compare one Dundee's to another. You have to put them together, marry them, watch them together. And there you have your A plus pin drop. I did a visual bit on our podcast.
在所有人当中，居然是迈尔斯·斯科特，谁能想到呢。接招吧，迈尔斯·麦克纳特。这就是我想说的。加油，奥特姆。我觉得你不能把一届邓迪奖和另一届进行比较。你必须把它们放在一起，结合起来，一起看。这样你就得到了一个满分的闪光点。我在我们的播客上做了一个视觉表演。
You sure did. You sure did. It's your special talent. You guys, that was Michael's last Dundee's. Big thank you. Oh, big thank you to Mindy Kaling for sending in audio clips. Thank you, Randy Cordray, for all your tidbits. Thank you to Sam and Cassie and Angela, our very own Michael Scott.
你确实做了。你真的做了。这是你的特殊才华。各位，那是迈尔斯的最后一次邓迪奖。非常感谢。哦，非常感谢敏迪·卡灵发来音频片段。感谢兰迪·科德雷提供的所有花絮。感谢山姆、卡西和安吉拉，我们自己的迈尔斯·斯科特。
Have a great week. We're taking next week off, but we'll be back with Goodbye, Michael. Oh my goodness. I know I'm not ready. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer,
祝大家过个愉快的一周。我们下周休息，但我们会带着《再见，迈尔斯》回归。哦天哪。我知道我还没准备好。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，
and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的助理制作人是英斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。想要无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。要免费试用一个月的Stitcher Premium，请使用代码 OFFICE。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。